Avant que la vidéo ne commence, j’ai une
question à vous poser :
Vous croyez VRAIMENT que les gens ont lu tous
les livres dont ils parlent ?
Bien sûr que non — sinon on ne pourrait
pas parler de grand-chose.
Eh oui, il y a vingt-quatre heures dans une
journée, et il faut travailler, manger, dormir,
et sortir le chien.
Donc le secret de la culture générale, ce
n’est PAS de lire des livres.
C’est quoi alors ?
Eh bien en fait, il n’y a pas qu’un seul
secret, il y en a CINQ.
Les étudiants et les personnes les plus cultivés,
les profs, et les intellectuels CONNAISSENT
ces cinq secrets, mais ils se gardent bien
d’en parler…
Les gens qui les découvrent réussissent
à développer RAPIDEMENT et FACILEMENT leur
culture générale, parce que leur rapport
au savoir A CHANGÉ.
Et une fois qu’ils APPLIQUENT les cinq secrets,
ils comprennent toutes les références des
personnes cultivées ;
ils savent s’exprimer avec profondeur sur
n’importe quel sujet ;
ils brillent par leur culture dans les conversations
et dans les débats ;
et ils ont le recul nécessaire pour faire
preuve d’esprit critique.
Ça vous intéresse ?
Eh bien je vous révèle les cinq secrets,
et je vous explique comment les appliquer
DÈS AUJOURD’HUI
pour vous cultiver DIX FOIS PLUS RAPIDEMENT
SANS VOUS PRENDRE LA TÊTE.
Pour recevoir les cinq secrets, inscrivez-vous
simplement soit en cliquant sur le lien qui
apparaît maintenant en haut à droite de
la vidéo, soit en cliquant sur celui qui
est dans la description de la vidéo.
C’est l’histoire de 10 secondes, donc
faites-le maintenant,
et vous pourrez découvrir le premier secret,
qui vous attendra bien au chaud dans votre
boîte mail après avoir regardé cette vidéo.
Voilà voilà, je vous ai dit ce que je voulais
vous dire.
Bonne vidéo !
1ère référence : De la démocratie en Amérique
(1835), Alexis de Tocqueville
En 2004, l’écrivain français Bernard-Henri
Lévy (« BHL » pour les intimes) accepte
une proposition du magazine américain The
Atlantic Monthly : faire un long voyage en
Amérique sur les traces d’Alexis de Tocqueville,
plus de 170 ans plus tard, pour donner à
l’Amérique un nouveau diagnostic extérieur
sur l’état de la démocratie. American
Vertigo, le livre qui compile les chroniques
de BHL, sera un best-seller aux États-Unis.
De la démocratie en Amérique est une référence
incontournable en science politique parce
que c’est la première analyse approfondie
de la réalité démocratique. C’est certes
un livre de philosophie politique, car Tocqueville
parle de l’essence et de l’idéal de la
politique — mais il est un précurseur de
la science politique dans la mesure où il
produit une étude systématique du système
politique démocratique, des forces à l’œuvre
dans ce système, ainsi que de la relation
entre ce système et les mentalités.
De la démocratie en Amérique est subdivisé
en 2 tomes d’environ 500 pages chacun (autrement
dit, c’est pour les courageux). Le premier
tome examine comment la démocratie façonne
le gouvernement et la vie politique aux États-Unis.
Le second se concentre sur l'influence de
la démocratie sur la société civile et
évoque les risques de ce régime politique.
Comme les auteurs du XIXe siècle, Tocqueville
commet souvent des phrases longues et complexes.
Son style est donc exigeant pour un lecteur
du XXIe siècle.
Quelles sont les idées essentielles de De
la démocratie en Amérique qui ont un intérêt
spécifique pour la science politique ?
Il y a tout d’abord l’enjeu de l’association.
Tocqueville note dans le tome II que les Américains
ont une forte tendance à s’associer. « L'Amérique,
écrit-il, est le pays du monde où l'on a
tiré le plus de parti de l'association. » Quels
que soient leur âge ou leur mentalité, les
individus participent à une multitude d’associations,
petites ou grandes, pour défendre leurs intérêts,
leurs valeurs ou leurs croyances. En France,
en comparaison, c’est le gouvernement qui
intervient pour faire ce que font les citoyens
américains en s’associant. Les Français
se méfient des groupes d’intérêt, c’est
pourquoi ils les subordonnent au pouvoir politique.
En revanche, les Américains font confiance
aux groupes d’intérêts indépendants et
estiment même qu’ils contribuent à la
vitalité démocratique.
La puissance de l’opinion publique en démocratie
est une autre idée essentielle du livre.
Pour Tocqueville, l’opinion publique est
le pouvoir dominant aux États-Unis, et c’est
ce qui fait de la souveraineté du peuple
une réalité de chaque jour. Mais comment
expliquer cette domination de l’opinion
publique ? C’est un effet pervers du fonctionnement
des régimes démocratiques. Étant donné
que les citoyens sont égaux, la règle de
la majorité est le seul moyen pratique pour
prendre des décisions concernant le destin
collectif. Et alors les citoyens survalorisent
l’opinion de la majorité. Ils risquent
donc de l’imposer aux minorités avec une
intransigeance qui dépasse celle des régimes
autoritaires. C’est ce que Tocqueville appelle
« la tyrannie de la majorité ».
Une troisième idée importante pour la science
politique, c’est la décentralisation. C’était
un enjeu très discuté en France au moment
de la rédaction du livre. Tocqueville estime
que la distribution du pouvoir entre de nombreux
niveaux et organes est un élément essentiel
du succès de la démocratie américaine.
Tout d’abord, cela empêche bien sûr la
tyrannie (puisque le pouvoir n’est pas concentré).
Ensuite, cela permet de prendre de meilleures
décisions, parce que les décideurs sont
proches des citoyens concernés par leurs
décisions. Enfin, la décentralisation incite
les citoyens à s’engager dans la gouvernance
locale. En résumé, elle protège la liberté
et rend les citoyens meilleurs.
De la démocratie en Amérique deviendra une
référence incontournable en science politique
à plusieurs égards. En premier lieu, l’approche
intellectuelle de Tocqueville est un modèle.
Il a fait « une étude de terrain » ; il
réfléchit avec le recul dépassionné d’un
scientifique ; il mêle la sociologie, l’histoire
et le droit. En deuxième lieu, De la démocratie
en Amérique traite déjà de certains thèmes
majeurs de la science politique, tels les
groupes d’intérêt, la culture politique,
la distribution du pouvoir, et bien sûr la
démocratie. En troisième lieu, les conclusions
de Tocqueville sont toujours valables de nos
jours.
Les Américains reconnaissent dans De la démocratie
en Amérique une image fidèle de leur pays.
Il faut dire que, contrairement à BHL, Tocqueville
ne s’était pas contenté de rencontrer
l’élite — il avait également fréquenté
des fermiers, des artisans et des petits commerçants.
2ème référence : Qu'est-ce qu'une nation
? (1882), Ernest Renan
Karl Deutsch, un Tchèque qui a été prof
de science politique dans les plus prestigieuses
universités américaines, a caricaturé la
définition de la nation de Renan en disant
: « Une nation est un groupe de personnes
unies par une vision erronée du passé et
la haine de leurs voisins ». C’est une
caricature, mais c’est vrai que Renan met
en évidence la part de croyance sur laquelle
repose une nation.
Qu'est-ce qu'une nation ? est une référence
incontournable en science politique parce
que c’est le socle intellectuel des travaux
sur le nationalisme. Renan rejette les fantasmes
qui sont couramment associés à l’idée
de nation. Ce faisant, il permet d’étudier
ce « mode de groupement », comme il l’appelle,
sans que l’idéologie ne déforme la réalité.
Ce livre est court et lisible parce qu’il
est tiré d’une conférence donnée à la
Sorbonne en 1882 (une conférence ne peut
pas durer 10 heures, et le conférencier doit
faire un effort pour conserver l’attention
de son public). Les phrases sont parfois longues
et les références historiques ne sont pas
toujours évidentes — mais rien d’insurmontable.
La démonstration est divisée en 3 parties
: 1° Renan retrace d’abord l’origine
historique de la nation ; 2° il invalide
ensuite les conceptions qui fondent la nation
sur des critères prétendument objectifs,
et montre ainsi ce que la nation n’est pas
; 3° enfin, il donne sa propre définition
en proposant une articulation originale entre
un peuple et son histoire.
Quelles sont les principales idées à retenir
pour la science politique ?
En premier lieu, la nation n’est pas une
entité fixe définie par des critères objectifs.
Ni la race (qui est une chimère), ni la langue,
ni la religion ne permettent de fonder une
nation. Il s’agit en réalité d’une innovation
historique. Il n’y avait pas de nations
dans l’Antiquité — ce sont les invasions
germaniques qui ont divisé l’Empire romain
d’Occident en nations en imposant des dynasties
et des aristocraties militaires. Or, les nouvelles
entités politiques n’avaient pas d’unité
raciale. Bien au contraire, elles ont fait
fusionner différentes populations.
La deuxième idée essentielle pour la science
politique est que le fondement de la nation
est psychologique. C’est pour ça que Renan
écrit que la nation est « une âme, un principe
spirituel ». La réalité de la nation repose
en dernière instance sur le désir (« la
volonté », dit Renan) et le sentiment d’appartenance
de ses membres. Pour être plus précis, le
phénomène psychologique a deux composantes
: d’une part, l’adhésion au passé de
la communauté, à son héritage historique
; d’autre part, le désir de perpétuer
cet héritage par la vie commune (« vouloir
faire de grandes choses ensemble », écrit
Renan).
La troisième idée essentielle de la conférence
est celle qui a occasionné la caricature
de Karl Deutsch : le sentiment d’appartenance
partagé par tous les membres de la nation
repose en partie sur l’erreur historique.
« L’essence d’une nation, écrit Renan,
est que tous les individus aient beaucoup
de choses en commun, et aussi que tous aient
oublié bien des choses. » « France » est
par exemple devenu le nom du pays alors même
qu’il n’était entré qu’une imperceptible
minorité de Francs. Renan va même jusqu’à
dire que le travail des historiens menace
l’idée de nationalité.
Ces conclusions ont permis à la réflexion
de la science politique de prendre beaucoup
de recul par rapport à la mythologie de la
nation. L’histoire montre que les formes
de la société humaine sont très variées
: grande agglomération, tribu, cité, empire,
communauté sans patrie, nation, confédération,
parenté raciale ou linguistique, etc. Renan
est, comme Tocqueville, un précurseur de
la science politique dans la mesure où il
étudie — lui, à travers l’histoire — la
réalité politique. Il est encore précurseur
dans la mesure où il étudie cette réalité
politique sur la longue durée (contrairement
aux journalistes, par exemple).
L’influence de Qu'est-ce qu'une nation ? dépasse
la seule science politique. En effet, cette
conférence est la source principale de la
conception de la nation qui prévaut désormais
dans les opinions publiques occidentales.
L’idée de nation a perdu une bonne partie
de son crédit au XXe siècle, mais elle conserve
une légitimité à travers la conception
de Renan. Pour faire simple, on dit que c’est
la conception « française », « subjective
», donc « ouverte » — et on oppose cette
conception dite « française » à la conception
dite « allemande » (car théorisée au début
du XIXe siècle par le philosophe Fichte),
conception allemande dite « objective », donc
« fermée » — et c’est cette conception
dite « allemande » que les opinions publiques
occidentales disqualifient désormais comme
xénophobe.
3ème référence : Les partis politiques
(1911), Robert Michels
Dans La Chute de la Maison Mélenchon (un
essai publié fin 2019), le politologue Thomas
Guénolé accuse Jean-Luc Mélenchon de diriger
son parti La France insoumise comme un dictateur
alors même qu’il plaide sans cesse pour
« une vraie démocratie ». Vous allez voir
que le sociologue allemand Robert Michels
avait expliqué cette contradiction 100 ans
plus tôt.
Ce livre, Les partis politiques, est une des
références sur les rapports de pouvoir au
sein des organisations politiques. Dans le
détail, Michels analyse l’émergence de
partis ouvriers dans les démocraties de masse,
et il en tire des conclusions sur la réalité
de la démocratie. C’est bien de la science
politique, car la réflexion est nourrie par
les contacts de Michels avec des partis politiques
et des syndicats en Allemagne et en Italie.
La nouvelle traduction française de son travail
(désormais intitulée « Sociologie du parti
dans la démocratie moderne ») représente
un pavé de plus de 800 pages. Comme les auteurs
de son époque, Michels rassemble de longues
phrases en de longs paragraphes. Mais il y
a pire. Ça reste lisible : le vocabulaire
n’est pas trop technique ; les références
historiques sont plutôt classiques ; et le
style est assez clair.
Ce livre est souvent résumé à l’idée
de la « loi d’airain » de l’oligarchie
(et c’est largement suffisant pour votre
culture générale).
Robert Michels a trouvé cette loi en constatant
une contradiction, pour parler comme les marxistes.
D’un côté, les organisations ouvrières
affirment leur attachement à la démocratie
et fonctionnent avec les attributs de la pratique
démocratique. Mais de l’autre côté, leurs
dirigeants ne changent pas ; ils ont tous
les mêmes profils ; et ils se serrent les
coudes.
Comment expliquer cette contradiction ?
L’origine en est que les partis politiques
se bureaucratisent. Comme toute organisation,
plus ils s’agrandissent, plus le travail
se divise, et plus les décisions se complexifient.
Un personnel administratif spécialisé est
tout particulièrement nécessaire pour la
mobilisation politique et le fonctionnement
quotidien du parti. Or, les administrateurs
ont besoin de connaissances spécifiques (juridiques,
économiques, etc.) et de compétences (préparation
de discours, rédaction de textes divers,
etc.). Or, cela demande une formation que
ne peuvent pas suivre les prolétaires. C’est
pour ça que les intellectuels sont si importants
dans les partis ouvriers. « Seul le socialiste
d’origine bourgeoise, écrit Robert Michels,
possède ce qui manque encore totalement au
prolétariat : le temps et les moyens de faire
son éducation politique, la liberté physique
de se transporter d’un endroit à un autre
et l’indépendance matérielle sans laquelle
l’exercice d’une action politique au sens
vrai et propre du mot est inconcevable. »
Le problème, c’est que ces élites bureaucratiques
vont s’émanciper : elles font prévaloir
leur intérêt de caste sur l’intérêt
originel du parti. Concrètement, elles focalisent
la stratégie du mouvement sur la conquête
de trophées électoraux et de postes de pouvoir
au sein des institutions établies. Le discours
est toujours révolutionnaire, mais l’action
est celle d’un parti d’opposition — un
parti que Michels qualifie de « conservateur
». La logique du développement d’une organisation
aboutit donc à une inversion des rapports
: « L’organisation, affirme Michels, est
ce qui donne lieu à la domination des élus
sur les électeurs, des mandataires sur les
mandants, des délégués sur les délégants.
[Et c’est après cette phrase que Michels
écrit sa fameuse formule] Qui dit organisation,
dit oligarchie ».
Or, cette conclusion ne vaut pas qu’à l’intérieur
du parti. En effet, une démocratie est un
vaste système avec son organisation. Donc,
comme dans un parti politique, des élites
dirigeantes émergent ; puis, derrière de
belles paroles, elles substituent leur intérêt
— qui est de rester au pouvoir afin d’en
conserver les avantages — elles substituent
leur intérêt à celui du peuple. Normalement,
le peuple peut changer ses responsables politiques.
Mais ceux-ci entravent le renouvellement des
élites dirigeantes (ils empêchent notamment
l’émergence de concurrents issus de la
masse populaire).
Pour Michels, la nécessaire organisation
d’un système démocratique rend donc impossible
la démocratie elle-même. C’est pour ça
qu’il dit qu’il écrit, je cite, « avec
l’intention de démolir quelques-unes des
faciles et superficielles illusions démocratiques
».
Avec une telle conclusion, le livre a eu une
influence limitée en science politique (comme
l’atteste le fait que les manuels l’évoquent
rapidement). La « loi d’airain » de l’oligarchie
est pourtant pertinente pour analyser tous
types d’organisations — les entreprises,
les syndicats, les administrations publiques,
et bien sûr les partis politiques. Seulement,
une organisation ne peut pas perdurer si les
membres pensent que leur élite agit pour
son propre compte (même si c’est vrai).
Il est donc naturel que le monde académique
des démocraties occidentales ne soit pas
enthousiaste à l'égard d'une théorie qui
conclut que la démocratie est une illusion
entretenue par les dirigeants politiques.
Après, Michels ne diabolise pas la démocratie.
Comme Pareto — ils sont tous les deux membres
de l'école italienne de sociologie des élites
— comme Pareto, Michels voit les régimes
politiques comme des systèmes de sélection
et de légitimation de l’élite dirigeante.
Et à cet égard, la démocratie est un moindre
mal parce que, de toute manière, la masse
populaire est passive et a besoin d’un leader.
Déçu par la démocratie et le socialisme,
Michels embrasse finalement le fascisme en
1928 (ce qui lui permet d’obtenir un poste
de professeur à l’université). Cette conversion
est peut-être une autre raison de l’influence
limitée de son livre en science politique.
4ème référence : Tableau politique de la
France de l’Ouest (1913), André Siegfried
On évoque parfois l’adage « Ceux qui ne
savent pas faire enseignent » pour se moquer
de ceux qui enseignent dans un domaine où
ils ont eux-mêmes échoué (je connais par
exemple quelqu’un qui a été embauché
comme prof de stratégie dans une école de
commerce avec pour seule expérience une période
d’essai [non renouvelée] dans un cabinet
de conseil en stratégie peu prestigieux).
On pourrait aussi appliquer l’adage à André
Siegfried. Inspiré par l’exemple de son
père (qui a été maire, député, et ministre),
il se présente au moins 4 fois à une élection
dans les années 1900 — et il échoue à
chaque fois. Un an après son dernier échec,
il abandonne toute ambition politique et devient
prof à l’École libre des sciences politiques
(l’ancêtre de Sciences Po), où il avait
lui-même étudié. Et quelques années plus
tard, il écrit un ouvrage fondateur de la
science politique française (en particulier
sur la question des élections).
Son Tableau politique de la France de l’Ouest
est plus précisément considéré comme l’œuvre
fondatrice de ce qu’on appelle la « géographie
électorale ». La première phrase du livre
en est emblématique : « J’ai remarqué
souvent, dans les élections, que les opinions
politiques sont sujettes à une répartition
géographique ».
La géographie électorale, c’est l’étude
de l’influence de facteurs tels que la répartition
des électeurs sur le territoire, les caractéristiques
géographiques d'une circonscription, ou encore
les schémas de vote régionaux — c’est
l’étude de l’influence de ces facteurs
sur les résultats des élections. Par exemple,
la géographie électorale établit que dans
la France contemporaine, les régions urbaines
comme Paris, Lyon et Marseille ont tendance
à voter davantage pour des partis de gauche,
tandis que les régions rurales et les petites
villes votent plutôt pour les partis de droite.
Autre exemple : aux États-Unis, il y a une
division géographique entre États républicains
(qui sont dits « rouges ») et États démocrates
(qui sont dits « bleus ») — et ça, c’est
aussi un résultat de la géographie électorale.
Avec la géographie électorale, on est bien
dans de la science politique, puisqu’il
s’agit d’analyser des observations et
des données concrètes.
Maintenant, que retenir du livre lui-même
?
Sur la forme, le Tableau politique de la France
de l’Ouest d’André Siegfried est un gros
pavé de 700 pages (le genre de livre qui
peut remplacer un haltère en cas de confinement).
D’un côté, le style est plutôt clair
: le propos est structuré efficacement ; le
style est parfois direct ; la longueur des
phrases varie ; les paragraphes ne sont pas
interminables (même plutôt courts, comparés
à ceux des auteurs d’avant internet). André
Siegfried ne pouvait pas utiliser de grande
quantité de données statistiques comme aujourd’hui,
mais il appuie et clarifie son propos grâce
à des cartes. Après, la lecture est quand
même rendue fastidieuse par l’addition
des études régionales détaillées.
Quel est l’essentiel sur le fond, maintenant
?
André Siegfried cherche à expliquer les
pratiques de vote dans les territoires de
la France de l’Ouest (la Vendée, la Bretagne,
l’Anjou [l’actuel Maine-et-Loire], et
le Maine) entre 1871 et 1910. Il analyse donc
les résultats des élections en fonction
des territoires.
Il constate qu’il y a une continuité des
préférences politiques dans le temps, c’est-à-dire
que les gens votent pour les mêmes bords
politiques : c’est ce qu’il appelle le
« tempérament politique ». Or, à ses yeux,
le tempérament politique tient fondamentalement
à des variables environnementales ou écologiques.
En clair, le vote s’explique par LE MILIEU
dans lequel les électeurs évoluent au quotidien
(l’homme comme produit de son milieu est
un paradigme très en vogue depuis le XIXe
siècle).
Cette perspective permet à André Siegfried
d’élucider le vote de droite et le vote
de gauche, ce qui donne sa célèbre formule
: « Le granit vote à droite, le calcaire
vote à gauche ».
Quel est le rapport entre ces matériaux naturels
et le vote ?
Prenons le granit. Les terres granitiques
produisent un terrain accidenté et retiennent
l’eau, ce qui permet de disperser les habitations
autour de nombreux puits. Cela rend possible
de grandes fermes possédées par de grands
propriétaires. Les communautés sont plus
repliées sur elles-mêmes et plus fortement
hiérarchisés. Les gens se rassemblent surtout
à l’occasion de la messe, d’où l’influence
de l’Église. La mentalité est dès lors
globalement conservatrice : elle résiste
au changement politique. Le granit vote donc
à droite.
Prenons maintenant le calcaire. Ce type de
terre est imperméable, en conséquence de
quoi les habitations doivent se concentrer
autour des rares points d’eau. Cela donne
une population de petits et moyens propriétaires
qui ont des relations plus égalitaires. Comme
les gens se rencontrent plus facilement, l’influence
de l’Église est moindre. Cet environnement
donne une mentalité plus ouverte au changement.
Voici, en résumé, le mécanisme de la thèse
: la morphologie de l’habitat détermine
les relations entre les groupes à l’intérieur
de la société (qui est une communauté de
communautés, comme dit Aristote), et ces
relations entre les groupes déterminent les
valeurs de la société (et donc le vote).
Après, André Siegfried évoque aussi d’autres
facteurs. Il y a notamment le poids de l’histoire.
Par exemple, l’Ouest a été marqué par
la résistance royaliste lors de la Révolution
française. Il y a encore le rapport de la
campagne à la ville.
Le Tableau politique de la France de l’Ouest
d’André Siegfried est un livre fondateur
pour la science politique contemporaine parce
qu’il pose le cadre d’analyse dans lequel
la discipline se développera au XXe siècle.
Tout d’abord, il ne peut plus y avoir de
doute, la politique est bien l’objet d’une
science : il y a des lois à découvrir. Voici
ce qu’André Siegfried écrit dans les dernières
lignes de l’introduction : « D’après
une opinion courante, les élections ne sont
qu’un domaine d’incohérence et de fantaisie.
En les observant à la fois de près et de
haut, je suis arrivé à une conclusion contraire.
Si, selon le mot de Goethe, "l’enfer même
a ses lois", pourquoi la politique n’aurait-elle
pas les siennes ? ». Et pour découvrir ces
lois, Siegfried mène une étude empirique
qui repose sur un véritable travail d’enquête
: il a visité les principaux cantons, échangé
avec les habitants, lu les journaux locaux,
et consulté les archives.
Ensuite, ce travail est également fondateur
pour l’analyse du vote. Le politiste doit
distinguer les facteurs de l’influence de
l’environnement sur l’électeur, et être
tout particulièrement attentif aux spécificités
de l’environnement local. Certes, le schéma
précis développé dans le Tableau politique
de la France de l’Ouest ne fonctionne pas
pour toutes les régions, mais la perspective
intellectuelle qui le sous-tend va s’imposer.
Enfin, l’analyse poussée d’André Siegfried
le fait anticiper sur des idées qui deviendront
importantes en science politique, comme la
distinction entre la sensibilité politique
et le statut économique de l’électeur
; ou encore la tendance des responsables politiques
à manipuler la délimitation des circonscriptions
électorales à leur bénéfice (ce qu’on
appelle le « gerrymandering », du nom d’un
homme politique américain, Elbridge Gerry,
qui avait approuvé une carte électorale
de forme très étrange).
5ème référence : Le Savant et le Politique
(1919), Max Weber
Historiquement, les premiers États ressemblaient
davantage à des systèmes de racket organisé,
dans lesquels de puissants mafieux extorquaient
des ressources aux autochtones et leur garantissaient
en retour une protection contre des ennemis
extérieurs ou intérieurs. Mais la comparaison
entre un État occidental moderne et une mafia
semble peu pertinente. Pourtant, il y a bien
un lien — c’est une des idées profondes
qui sont dans ce livre.
Weber affirmait qu’il n’était pas un
homme politique et qu’il n’avait pas l’intention
de le devenir. Cependant, comme beaucoup de
penseurs politiques, il a parfois rêvé de
jouer un véritable rôle politique (il a
par exemple envisagé une candidature au Reichstag,
le parlement allemand, en 1918). Malgré cette
ambition concrète, son propos est trop abstrait
pour relever de la science politique au sens
moderne. Le politiste allemand Wilhelm Hennis,
qui était un spécialiste de la pensée de
Max Weber, estime même qu’il est, je cite,
« le dernier véritable penseur politique
classique » (dans la lignée de Machiavel,
Rousseau, ou Tocqueville). Que fait donc ce
livre dans ma liste ? Eh bien, plusieurs de
ses idées sont essentielles dans la science
politique contemporaine, au point que Max
Weber est une des références les plus récurrentes
dans les manuels.
Sur la forme, Le Savant et le Politique est
un des livres les plus accessibles de Max
Weber, parce que c’est le texte d’une
conférence. Le propos est donc relativement
clair et vivant par rapport au style académique
rigoureux de l’époque. Il y a des phrases
courtes ; il y a des questions ; les paragraphes
sont plutôt courts ; et Max Weber accompagne
son audience dans le développement de son
propos avec des phrases de transition. Après,
certains passages sont longs et abstraits,
au point que même un lecteur avec une formation
intellectuelle doit s’accrocher.
Quoi retenir sur le fond, maintenant ?
Je pense qu’il y a 3 choses essentielles
pour la science politique :
1. la définition de la politique ;
2. la définition du pouvoir (à travers les
notions d'autorité et d'État) ;
3. la description du métier d’homme politique.
Tout d’abord, comment Max Weber définit-il
la politique ?
Il donne sa réponse dès le deuxième paragraphe.
Il commence par souligner la diversité des
sens du mot « politique » : on parle bien
de la politique d’une banque, de la politique
d’un syndicat au cours d’une grève, de
la politique scolaire d’une commune rurale,
et même de la politique d’une femme qui
soumet son mari. Weber estime que ce qu’il
y a de crucial dans tous ces différents sens,
c’est la domination de l’homme par l’homme.
Il définit donc la politique comme l’ensemble
des efforts que l’on fait en vue de participer
au pouvoir ou d’influencer la répartition
du pouvoir, soit entre les États, soit entre
divers groupes au sein d’un même État.
La notion de politique est donc liée aux
notions de pouvoir et d’État.
Weber élucide le pouvoir via la notion d’autorité.
Il définit l’autorité comme la chance
de faire triompher, au sein d’une relation
sociale, sa propre volonté, même contre
la résistance des autres. Or, il y a une
dimension psychologique cruciale dans un rapport
d’autorité. Le subordonné doit croire
en la supériorité du supérieur et en la
nécessité de lui obéir. C’est ce que
Weber appelle la « légitimité ». Cela
signifie que la domination du dominant est
reconnue et admise par le dominé.
L’idée de la légitimité est importante
parce qu’elle permet de distinguer 3 formes
d’autorité. Il y a tout d’abord l’autorité
qui repose sur une légitimité traditionnelle.
Dans ce cas, le subordonné croit au caractère
sacré des traditions — c’est-à-dire
à tout ce que valorisaient les générations
passées et qu’elles ont transmis à leurs
héritiers — et le subordonné croit par
conséquent à la légitimité de ceux qui
ont été appelés par la tradition à exercer
l’autorité. Son obéissance est alors personnelle
: il obéit au dominant désigné par la tradition.
La deuxième forme d’autorité repose sur
une légitimité charismatique. Comment définir
le charisme ? C’est la capacité d’un
individu à fasciner d’autres individus.
L’étymologie du mot (kharisma, « grâce
accordée par Dieu ») signifie que le charme
de l’individu charismatique semble surnaturel.
Max Weber distingue deux cas : soit c’est
la personne elle-même qui est charismatique
(un prophète, par exemple) ; soit c’est
la fonction qui produit le charisme (la fonction
de président de la République française
a par exemple en elle-même la capacité de
fasciner les individus).
L’autorité traditionnelle et l’autorité
charismatique sont des formes anciennes d’autorité.
La dernière des trois est une forme moderne
: c’est l’autorité « légale-rationnelle
». Dans cet adjectif, il y a l’idée de
loi, parce que l’individu obéit non pas
à un autre individu, mais à une règle,
c’est-à-dire à une formule générale
qui prescrit ce qu’il faut faire. Et puis
dans l’adjectif « légal-rationnel » il
y a aussi l’idée de raison, dont les règles
tirent précisément leur force. Il faut obéir
aux règles parce qu’elles sont nées de
l’effort de l’intelligence humaine.
Dans la réalité, une autorité est toujours
un mélange des 3 formes théorisées par
Weber. Par exemple, l’autorité du président
de la République française est traditionnelle
parce que ce régime politique a une histoire
; cette autorité est aussi toujours charismatique,
comme l’attestent toutes les mises en scène
du pouvoir du président ; enfin, de nos jours,
elle est surtout légale-rationnelle, car
elle repose sur des règles qui ont été
élaborées méticuleusement (et les législateurs
continuent de les faire évoluer).
L’exemple qui me vient spontanément à
l’esprit est celui du président de la République
parce que, comme le dit Max Weber dès le
début de la conférence, dans nos sociétés,
le détenteur du pouvoir politique est l’État.
Mais qu’est-ce que l’État ? On arrive
là à l’idée que j’ai évoquée au tout
début, le lien entre un État et une mafia.
Pour Max Weber, l’État ne se définit pas
fondamentalement par les acteurs, personnes
ou entités, qui le constituent ni par les
buts qu’il poursuit, mais par le moyen spécifique
qui lui est propre : le monopole de la violence
physique légitime. C’est la célèbre définition
de l’État de Max Weber. Je vous la cite
in extenso : « Il faut concevoir l’État
contemporain comme une communauté humaine
qui, dans les limites d’un territoire déterminé
revendique avec succès pour son propre compte
le monopole de la violence physique légitime
».
Historiquement, l’État moderne s’est
constitué en expropriant les autorités locales
afin de centraliser le pouvoir. Comme la mafia,
il obtient la soumission des citoyens en leur
offrant sa protection, en vertu de quoi les
violences privées sont interdites.
La dernière chose essentielle pour la science
politique dans ce livre est la description
du métier d’homme politique. Deux idées
se sont particulièrement imposées.
Il y a tout d’abord les deux éthiques — ou
les deux morales, si on veut — possibles
en politique. L’homme politique peut d’abord
agir selon une éthique de responsabilité.
Cela signifie que ce sont les résultats de
son action qui lui importent. Il est donc
capable, dans l’esprit de Machiavel, de
recourir à des moyens immoraux pour le bien
de la collectivité. L’homme politique peut
ensuite agir selon une éthique de conviction.
Là, au contraire, ce sont ses sentiments,
ses valeurs, ses idées qui déterminent son
action — et le problème c’est qu’il
peut faire le mal en ayant voulu faire le
bien. Les idéalistes, qui méconnaissent
les contraintes de la réalité, obéissent
à l’éthique de conviction. Après, les
deux éthiques sont combinées dans les faits,
comme le sont les 3 formes d’autorité.
La seconde idée importante qui décrit le
métier d’homme politique tient dans une
formule célèbre : « Ou bien on vit POUR
la politique ou on vit DE la politique ». Weber
oppose par là le dirigeant qui tire son revenu
de la politique au militant qui en tire son
épanouissement. Il y a un conflit entre deux
types d’acteurs, les professionnels et les
amateurs. Les premiers veulent gagner des
places et des avantages ; les seconds veulent
faire gagner leurs idées.
Pour finir, quelle influence ce livre a-t-il
eue en science politique ? Comme je l’ai
dit au début, Max Weber n’est pas un politiste.
L’abstraction de son propos n’est pas
en phase avec l’empirisme de la science
politique contemporaine. Pour autant, Le Savant
et le Politique a été influent à deux égards.
Il a lancé des thèmes et des idées sur
lesquels se sont appuyées les générations
de politistes jusqu’à aujourd’hui : le
pouvoir comme relation sociale (qui présuppose
le consentement du dominé) ; l’émergence
et le développement de l’État des points
de vue historique et sociologique ; ou encore
l’étude de la professionnalisation de la
vie politique. En second lieu, Le Savant et
le Politique témoigne du détachement que
Max Weber revendiquait à l’égard de la
politique — c’était à ses yeux la condition
nécessaire à l’objectivité. Il avait
une liberté de parole qui lui permettait
de dire des vérités dérangeantes, telles
l’origine mafieuse de l’État (même s’il
ne le dit pas tel quel), ou la tendance de
l’homme politique professionnel à sacrifier
les idées pour les places. Les politistes
revendiquent le même détachement et le même
recul.
6ème référence : The People's Choice (1948),
Paul Lazarsfeld
L’avocat Juan Branco écrit en 2019 dans
Crépuscule : « Emmanuel Macron a été "placé"
bien plus qu’il n’a été élu ». Il
estime que ce sont les grands médias français
qui ont fait l’élection présidentielle
de 2017. De son point de vue, les quelques
milliardaires qui en sont propriétaires — notamment
Xavier Niel, le patron fondateur de Free — ces
oligarques de l’hexagone ont mis tout leur
pouvoir d’influence au service du candidat
qui devait servir au mieux leurs intérêts.
Mais est-il aussi simple de « faire » l’opinion
? Vous me voyez venir : ce livre de 1948 donne
de sérieuses raisons d’en douter.
Comme le titre l’indique, The People’s
Choice (« Le choix du peuple » en français)
— The People’s Choice parle des facteurs
qui déterminent le choix des électeurs,
notamment en période électorale. Il n’y
a aucun doute sur le fait qu’il s’agit
bien de science politique, car le contenu
du livre repose sur des interviews et des
statistiques réalisés à partir d’un panel
d’électeurs pour les élections présidentielles
américaines de 1940 et 1944. La perspective
empirique de Paul Lazarsfeld transparaît
d’ailleurs dans le nom de l’institut qu’il
a fondé à la prestigieuse université de
Columbia où il officiait : le « Bureau pour
la recherche sociale appliquée ». Bref,
on est dans le concret.
Sur la forme, The People’s Choice est écrit
avec la clarté des auteurs américains (par
rapport aux auteurs européens). Le style
est plus simple ; les phrases et les paragraphes
plus courts. Après, comme il s’agit essentiellement
de l’analyse des résultats des enquêtes
menés par l’équipe de Paul Lazarsfeld,
ce n’est pas toujours passionnant. Et puis
il n’existe aucune traduction française
(à ma connaissance).
Qu’en retenir sur le fond, maintenant ?
La première idée essentielle du livre est
que les électeurs ont des préférences politiques
anciennes. Elles sont déterminées par les
caractéristiques sociales, telles que le
statut socio-économique, la religion, et
le lieu de résidence.
Comme nous sommes aux États-Unis, Paul Lazarsfeld
donne l’exemple des deux grands partis américains
:
* le vote républicain est majoritaire chez
les individus de statut élevé, chez les
protestants et chez les populations rurales
(près des trois quarts des électeurs républicains
correspondent ainsi à la figure du WASP [White
Anglo-saxon Protestant], « blanc anglo-saxon
protestant » en français) ;
* en revanche, le vote démocrate est majoritaire
chez les individus de statut peu élevé,
catholiques et urbains.
Si les préférences politiques sont anciennes,
c’est notamment en raison de l’empreinte
continue de la famille. La politique s’apprend
et se pratique d’abord en famille. C’est
plus particulièrement le couple qui est crucial.
Les gens manifestent, votent ou s’abstiennent
en couple. Et c’est avant tout à l’influence
respective des conjoints l’un sur l’autre
que l’on doit l’évolution des positions
politiques sur les grands enjeux de société
(notez que les femmes ont le droit de vote
depuis plus de 20 ans à l’époque de l’écriture
du livre).
Ainsi, l’opinion du conjoint, le statut,
la religion, et le lieu de résidence déterminent
le choix de l’électeur. C’est le modèle
d’interprétation du vote de l’université
de Columbia, modèle qui est déterministe.
Lazarsfeld écrit d’ailleurs « une personne
pense politiquement comme elle est socialement
». Précisément parlant, plus un électeur
possède certaines caractéristiques, plus
il a de chances de voter pour un parti.
Bref, ce seraient ce qu’on appelle les « variables
sociales lourdes » qui feraient l’élection.
Cette thèse détruit le mythe du citoyen
qui vote en son âme et conscience après
avoir étudié les programmes des candidats.
La seconde idée essentielle de The People’s
Choice concerne l’influence des médias.
Si les préférences politiques sont anciennes,
et si elles procèdent de facteurs sociaux
durables, alors l’influence des médias
est, elle, limitée. En effet, les électeurs
ne s’exposent qu’à une partie des messages,
et ce sont au contraire les relations personnelles
qui influencent de manière décisive leur
choix. Le contenu médiatique n’a d’effet
que sur une petite partie de l’électorat,
que le livre estime à moins de 5 %.
Mais cette influence n’est pas forcément
négligeable. Elle peut même finir par toucher
les électeurs qui n’ont jamais été exposés
à un message. Lazarsfeld explique ce phénomène
avec la théorie de la communication à deux
étages. Selon cette théorie, les messages
des médias sont reçus et filtrés par des
« leaders d’opinion », des individus ayant
un statut social élevé et une position centrale
au sein d'un groupe (par exemple des hommes
politiques, des éditorialistes, des syndicalistes
— mais aussi des pères de famille, ou encore
des chefs d’entreprise, etc.). L’influence
des médias est donc indirecte : un leader
d'opinion assimile leur message et le partage
ensuite avec son réseau.
The People’s Choice a eu une énorme influence
en science politique :
* il a d’abord fait du vote, et en particulier
des facteurs qui le déterminent, un thème
très fertile pour le développement de la
discipline ;
* il a ensuite imposé une innovation de méthode
: c’est le premier effort systématique
pour retracer le comportement des électeurs
pendant toute la durée d'une campagne présidentielle,
puis mettre à jour les données au cours
des années suivantes ;
* il a contribué à définir la perspective
intellectuelle particulière de la science
politique, qui mêle la sociologie (Lazarsfeld
était d’ailleurs sociologue de profession,
et il sera même président de l'Association
américaine de sociologie) — la perspective
intellectuelle du livre mêle la sociologie
et la psychologie (la mère de Lazarsfeld
était psychologue, et lui-même avait déjà
mené des travaux de psychologie) ;
* enfin, l’influence de The People’s Choice
en science politique, et plus généralement
dans la culture américaine, tient également
à la dissipation du fantasme de la manipulation
de l’opinion publique par les médias (un
fantasme bien sûr entretenu par les communicants,
de la même manière que les publicitaires
entretiennent le fantasme de la puissance
de persuasion de la publicité).
7ème référence : Les Origines du totalitarisme
(1951), Hannah Arendt
Selon un dicton populaire allemand, en démocratie,
tout ce qui n’est pas interdit est permis
; sous une dictature, tout ce qui n’est
pas permis est interdit ; et dans le totalitarisme,
tout ce qui n’est pas interdit est obligatoire.
C’est Mussolini qui, le premier, évoque
sa « féroce volonté totalitaire » dans
un discours de 1925 (3 ans après sa prise
de pouvoir). L’idée est théorisée 3 ans
plus tard dans la revue britannique The Contemporary
Review : elle voit le totalitarisme comme
étant le fait d’un État unitaire, à parti
unique, fasciste ou communiste, né d’une
réaction au parlementarisme.
Mais c’est à la philosophe et politologue
allemande Hannah Arendt que l’on doit l’analyse
de référence du totalitarisme (dans le 3ème
tome, intitulé Le système totalitaire, de
la trilogie Les Origines du totalitarisme
sortie en 1951). Son objectif est de compléter
la typologie des régimes politiques d'Aristote
en théorisant un mode de gouvernement sans
précédent.
Comme elle se place dans la lignée d’Aristote,
Hannah Arendt fait plutôt de la philosophie
politique. Pourquoi alors inclure ce livre
dans ma liste ? La première raison, c’est
qu’il se situe plutôt à la frontière
entre la philosophie politique et la science
politique. Il y a certes un travail de conceptualisation
des phénomènes politiques, mais il y a aussi
une analyse empirique — en particulier historique
— des régimes totalitaires. La seconde
raison, c’est que ce livre est la référence
intellectuelle sur un thème à la fois nouveau
et majeur pour la science politique à partir
de la seconde partie du XXe siècle.
Que dire concernant la forme ?
Au format poche, les 3 tomes totalisent environ
1000 pages — autrement dit, il faut s’accrocher.
Après, le propos est accessible. Avec presque
10 ans d’expérience dans le journalisme
aux États-Unis, Hannah Arendt sait écrire
clairement et conserver l’attention du lecteur.
Les phrases sont parfois longues et compliquées
; certains paragraphes se prolongent au-delà
du raisonnable — mais dans l’ensemble,
ça va. Il y a peu de jargon (ce qui est certainement
un autre fruit de l’expérience journalistique
de Hannah Arendt).
Quel est l’essentiel sur le fond, maintenant
?
Je vais me concentrer sur le 3ème tome, Le
système totalitaire, parce qu’il est celui
qui contient les idées importantes pour la
science politique.
Pour Hannah Arendt, le totalitarisme est un
phénomène politiquement inédit : il ne
rentre dans aucune des formes connues de despotisme,
de tyrannie ou de dictature. Il est la catégorie
qui permet d’expliquer les similitudes entre
le fascisme et le communisme, à élucider
à travers l’étude des cas de l’Allemagne
nazie et de l’URSS stalinienne.
Hannah Arendt souligne d’abord la dimension
sociologique du totalitarisme. En effet, elle
le définit comme un phénomène de « masses
». C’est le capitalisme qui, en détruisant
les solidarités traditionnelles, a engendré
ces masses, de grands groupes humains déstructurés
et amorphes. Les masses sont aisément manipulables
parce qu’elles sont désintéressées et
mentalement confuses. Enfoncées dans un mélange
de nihilisme et de désir de violence, elles
sont un terrain fertile pour l’idéologie
totalitaire.
Le totalitarisme se concrétise politiquement
par la prédominance d’un parti. Mais comment
ce parti peut-il avoir jusqu’à 90 % de
sympathisants ? Pour Hannah Arendt, c’est
parce que le parti totalitaire emploie des
techniques de persuasion dignes d’une secte.
L’adhésion massive repose sur une folie
collective entretenue par de grands rites
collectifs, et non pas sur une conviction
personnelle et rationnelle. L'individu existe
uniquement par son appartenance au parti,
ce qui crée une intense loyauté. En pratique,
d’ailleurs, le parti est structuré par
degrés d’initiation, comme dans les sociétés
secrètes. La dimension sectaire se trahit
également par le fait que le chef du parti
a une responsabilité totale. La puissance
du parti totalitaire culmine dans la dissolution
de l’État dans le parti unique. À partir
de là, il n’y a plus d’État de droit
ni d’espace public.
Cette situation aboutit à la déshumanisation
de l’homme. Non seulement le totalitarisme
supprime la liberté extérieure par la terreur,
mais il supprime aussi la liberté intérieure
en imposant à l’homme de donner du sens
à son existence par l’idéologie totalitaire.
Cela le plonge dans un mélange inédit de
désespoir et de folie qu’Arendt appelle
« désolation ».
Cette conclusion philosophique est très intéressante.
Comme le disait déjà Platon dans La République,
il y a un lien entre le régime politique
et la psychologie individuelle. Ce qu’il
y a dans l’esprit de l’homme, ses désirs
et ses valeurs, et d’autre part la manière
dont sa communauté est organisée — ce
ne sont pas du tout deux sujets différents.
Les Origines du totalitarisme est une référence
incontournable en science politique pour 3
raisons principales :
1. Hannah Arendt met à jour la typologie
des régimes politiques avec l’expérience
du XXe siècle ;
2. elle produit une description détaillée
des mécanismes des régimes totalitaires
;
3. elle a courage de rapprocher le communisme
et le fascisme (même si elle estime que l’URSS
de Lénine [qui était une dictature] et la
Chine communiste ne rentrent pas dans la catégorie
du totalitarisme).
Petite interruption parce que je me dis que
si vous aimez l’esprit de cette vidéo — à
savoir découvrir des choses intéressantes
en allant à l’essentiel et sans se prendre
la tête — alors vous aimerez probablement
mon programme Culture Express.
C’est un programme méthodique pour devenir
facilement une personne cultivée en seulement
quelques mois.
Il couvre tous les domaines de la culture
générale : vous maîtriserez les connaissances
essentielles sur l’histoire de l’humanité,
sur l’histoire de France, en économie,
en science politique, en psychologie, en science,
en littérature, en art, en religion, et en
philosophie.
Vous ne serez plus jamais à court de choses
à dire et vous gagnerez la confiance nécessaire
pour briller en toutes circonstances.
Vous pouvez en savoir plus en cliquant sur
le lien qui s’affiche en haut à droite,
ou bien sur celui qui est dans la description,
ou bien encore en tapant directement l’adresse
qui s’affiche à l’écran dans la barre
de recherche.
Mais je pense que la meilleure façon de vous
donner une idée du programme est d’écouter
ce que les membres ont à en dire.
Valentine, qui reconnaît l’énorme quantité
de travail que ce programme a représenté
pour moi, dit que « c’est une véritable
mine d’or [...] L’essentiel est là, tout
est simple, pratique, très bien expliqué,
concentré, il n’y a plus qu’à recopier
et à apprendre. Ce travail est vraiment formidable
et passionnant. »
Maxence m’écrit directement dans les commentaires
en-dessous d’une vidéo du programme : « Ta
formation est vraiment remarquable. J'étais
un peu dubitatif étant donné le prix initial
mais je ne regrette pas, c'est un vrai travail
de synthèse que tu nous proposes et le format
vidéo est très adapté pour moi qui ai une
mémoire essentiellement auditive. Le choix
des thèmes et des chapitres est pertinent
et je trouve que tu as trouvé la dose d'approfondissement
parfaite ; à la fois précis mais sans fioritures
! »
Vincent, lui, fait carrément ma pub : « J’ai
d’ailleurs recommandé votre formation à
ma sœur qui travaille comme diplomate [...]. La
semaine dernière, elle a déjà eu l’occasion
de mettre à profit, dans ses discussions,
les connaissances que vous avez diffusées.
»
Vous verrez d’autres témoignages comme
ceux-ci dans les commentaires si vous rejoignez
le programme. Et si vous vous inscrivez, vous
bénéficiez d'une garantie résultats : une
fois que vous aurez terminé le programme,
je vous rembourserai intégralement si vous
estimez que vous n’avez pas acquis une solide
culture générale.
Si vous voulez en savoir plus, cliquez sur
le lien qui s’affiche en haut à droite,
ou bien sur celui qui est dans la description,
ou bien encore tapez directement l’adresse
qui s’affiche à l’écran dans la barre
de recherche.
Plus de 800 membres ont déjà tiré parti
de ce programme, et je serais ravi qu’il
en soit de même pour vous.
8ème référence : Les partis politiques
(1951), Maurice Duverger
Étudiant, j’avais travaillé sur les élections
présidentielles américaines, et j’avais
été frappé par l’ultradomination des
deux grands partis, les démocrates et les
républicains. Lors de l’élection de Barack
Obama en 2008, par exemple, le candidat qui
arrive troisième ne recueille que 0,56 % des
suffrages, soit grosso modo 100 fois moins
que le candidat républicain qui arrive deuxième
! Là c’était un peu extrême — mais
de ce que je sais, en général le candidat
qui arrive troisième ne dépasse guère quelques
pourcents. En pratique, c’est comme s’il
n’y avait que deux candidats à cette élection.
C’est bien différent de l’élection présidentielle
française, où il peut y avoir de 3 à 5-6
gros candidats.
Ce phénomène est expliqué dans Les partis
politiques de Maurice Duverger. Ce livre est
incontournable parce qu’il est une référence
obligée lorsque l’on parle des partis politiques
(pas seulement en science politique, d’ailleurs).
Duverger ouvre même la 10ème édition (qui
date de 1981) en affirmant que son travail
demeure la meilleure explication des partis
politiques malgré toutes les théories importantes
qui ont été élaborées dans les 30 années
qui se sont écoulées depuis la 1ère édition.
Et puis c’est bien de la SCIENCE politique
parce que même si Duverger esquisse une théorie
générale des partis politiques, il s'appuie
sur l'observation empirique et sur l'analyse
comparative pour élaborer sa théorie.
Il existe des traductions en espagnol et en
anglais hors de prix sur Amazon, mais le livre
n’est même plus disponible — ni en papier,
ni sur Kindle — en français. On peut le
consulter gratuitement en version PDF sur
le site de la Bibliothèque nationale de France
(ce n’est pas l’idéal, mais ça permet
tout de même de travailler sur le livre).
Maurice Duverger a beau être un universitaire,
il a un vrai talent de vulgarisateur. Il était
d’ailleurs connu pour sa capacité à simplifier
des concepts politiques complexes et à les
rendre accessibles à un large public. Hormis
le socle minimal de culture politique et historique
nécessaire pour saisir les références,
le propos de ce livre est très accessible.
Duverger écrit de manière claire et concise,
en évitant les fioritures inutiles. Le texte
est structuré de manière logique, argument
par argument, avec des exemples concrets pour
étayer la théorie. Chaque paragraphe commence
par son idée directrice. Le style de Duverger
a même à certains moments une élégance
littéraire. Le seul défaut est celui de
l’immense majorité des auteurs de l’époque
: les paragraphes sont parfois trop longs.
Quoi retenir du fond de ce livre, maintenant
?
Maurice Duverger adopte une perspective originale.
À ses yeux, ce ne sont pas les idées politiques
qui définissent les partis modernes, mais
la nature de leur organisation, leur structure.
« Les partis modernes, écrit-il, se caractérisent
avant tout par leur anatomie ».
La 1ère idée essentielle du livre est la
célèbre distinction des deux types de parti
: les partis de cadres et les partis de masse.
Les partis de cadres sont apparus au XIXe
siècle avec l’émergence du droit de vote
et le développement des systèmes démocratiques.
Comme leur nom l’indique, ces partis sont
formés par des notables de la bourgeoisie
ou l'aristocratie. Ils sont peu hiérarchisés
parce qu’ils ont peu d’adhérents et qu’ils
reposent sur des réseaux locaux de notables.
Ce sont traditionnellement des partis de droite.
On donne en général l’exemple anglais
des partis Whigs (l’ancêtre du parti libéral
de gauche) et Tories (l’ancêtre du parti
conservateur) qui sont nés au XVIIe siècle.
Leur but était de faire élire leurs membres
au Parlement.
Le second type de parti, les partis de masse,
est apparu à la fin du XIXe siècle, et ces
partis ont connu une expansion significative
au cours du XXe siècle. Ils sont nés des
associations telles que les syndicats, qui
recherchaient la participation populaire et
qui étaient financés par cotisations. Comme
leur nom l’indique, ils ont une large base
d’adhérents — et ces adhérents viennent
forcément des classes populaires. De même,
il est forcément nécessaire d’organiser
la masse des adhérents, c’est pourquoi
les partis de masse sont fortement hiérarchisés
: la base est constituée par des sections
locales, coordonnées au niveau départemental
par des fédérations, elles-mêmes dépendantes
d’un centre. Enfin, ils ont également la
particularité de former leurs adhérents.
Le Parti communiste français de l’après-Seconde-Guerre
mondiale est emblématique de ce type de parti
: il a près de 800 000 adhérents et jouit
d’une énorme influence culturelle grâce
à des centres de formation, des clubs, des
journaux, des maisons d’édition ou des
syndicats.
La 2ème idée essentielle de ce livre est
ce qu’on appelle la « loi de Duverger ». Cette
loi dit que les règles de l’élection déterminent
la façon dont les partis s’organisent.
Ainsi, Duverger pose que la représentation
proportionnelle (lorsque les postes sont répartis
en proportion des votes obtenus par chaque
groupe politique) — la représentation proportionnelle
engendre un système de partis multiples,
rigides et indépendants les uns des autres
(c’est le cas en Allemagne, par exemple).
Ensuite, un scrutin majoritaire à deux tours
(c’est le fonctionnement de l’élection
présidentielle française) — un scrutin
majoritaire à deux tours engendre un système
de partis multiples, souples mais dépendants
les uns des autres (la coopération est nécessaire
pour former des alliances). Enfin, un scrutin
majoritaire à un tour engendre un dualisme
des partis. L’exemple le plus emblématique
est l’élection du président des États-Unis,
qui se résume, comme je vous l’ai dit au
tout début, à l’opposition du parti démocrate
et du parti républicain.
La 3ème idée essentielle de ce livre est
moins originale. Duverger dit que les partis
politiques sont des miroirs de la société.
Plus précisément, ils cristallisent la structure
sociale à un moment donné. Encore plus précisément,
la structuration des partis et leurs rapports
de force reflètent la structuration et les
rapports de force des divers groupes et mouvements
qui composent la société. Et comme la société
est une organisation dynamique qui évolue
avec le temps, la structuration de la vie
politique en partis évolue également.
Comment caractériser l’influence de ce
livre sur la science politique ? Tout d’abord,
c’est la première esquisse d’une théorie
générale des partis. Après la Seconde Guerre
mondiale, les politistes avaient déjà beaucoup
observé et décrit le fonctionnement des
partis , mais il y avait tant de nuances et
de complexités qu’il semblait impossible
de tout synthétiser sous quelques lois. Duverger
est conscient de la difficulté : il dit au
début du livre qu’une théorie générale
des partis est impossible, mais nécessaire.
La seconde dimension de l’influence de ce
livre est qu’il est emblématique de l’autonomisation
de la science politique par rapport au droit
public. La sociologie et l’histoire deviennent
plus importantes.
9ème référence : The American Voter (1960),
Angus Campbell
À quelques jours de l’élection présidentielle
française de 2002, le candidat centriste
François Bayrou se rend dans un quartier
de Strasbourg pour parler de sécurité. La
visite dérape en un instant : devant les
caméras, le candidat gifle un enfant de 11
ans en lui disant « Tu ne me fais pas les
poches ! ». Son équipe de campagne est morte
de peur, ses conseillers sont effondrés — certains
pensent même que c’est la fin de sa carrière
politique. Mais c’est l’inverse qui se
produit : bénéficiant d’une énorme couverture
médiatique, le geste fait remonter Bayrou
dans les sondages. Les électeurs le voient
comme un homme de principes qui peut remédier
au déclin de l’autorité de l’État.
Comment expliquer l’effet de la gifle ? Angus
Campbell avait donné la réponse 40 ans plus
tôt dans The American Voter.
Le psychologue américain estime qu’au milieu
des Trente Glorieuses, seul un citoyen américain
sur dix témoigne d'une compétence politique
conforme aux attendus de la mythologie républicaine.
Autrement dit, les électeurs qui votent après
s’être informés sur les programmes constituent
une infime minorité. Mais des auteurs qui
s’opposeront à cette thèse lui répliqueront
que, je cite, « les électeurs ne sont pas
des imbéciles ».
Combien dérangeante pour la démocratie,
la conclusion d’Angus Campbell a le mérite
d’être étayée. The American Voter s’inscrit
dans la prolifération des recherches sur
le vote dans les années 1950. C’est bien
de la science politique, car l’analyse repose
sur les données issues des élections de
la décennie, tout particulièrement l’élection
présidentielle américaine de 1956 (gagnée
par le président en exercice Eisenhower).
Comme le dit le titre, l'objectif du livre
est d'examiner le comportement de l'électeur
en tant qu'individu, et non de décrire l'électorat
dans son ensemble. Le propos relève donc
en partie de la psychologie.
Avec plus de 500 pages, The American Voter
est dense, mais accessible. D’un côté,
le style est formel et académique ; les paragraphes
sont parfois bien longs ; la profondeur théorique
peut intimider un lecteur amateur. De l’autre
côté, toutefois, Angus Campbell sait s’exprimer
de manière claire, parfois même directe
; son discours est bien structuré. Bref,
ce n’est pas un livre à emporter à la
plage — mais il n’y a pas de quoi avoir
les larmes aux yeux si, pour un quelconque
travail intellectuel, on doit se plonger dans
le texte.
Sur le fond, ce livre a imposé un modèle
d’interprétation du vote de référence
en science politique, le modèle de l’université
de Michigan (l’université de l’état
du nord des États-Unis dans laquelle officiait
Angus Campbell). Ce modèle s’oppose à
celui de l’université de Columbia (dont
je vous ai parlé) en revalorisant les facteurs
psychologiques individuels.
Il met surtout en évidence l’importance
de ce qu’il appelle « l’identification
partisane » : c’est un attachement d’ordre
quasi affectif de l’électeur à l’égard
d’un parti, d’un programme, ou d’un
candidat. Les enquêtes analysées dans le
livre montrent que l’identification partisane
est le principal déterminant du vote ; qu’il
est stable et prévisible ; et qu’il augmente
avec l’âge (autrement dit, plus l’électeur
vieillit, plus il s’attache à un camp politique,
même si son statut social a évolué). En
pratique, les partisans loyaux ont même tendance
à adapter leurs opinions sur les questions
spécifiques pour correspondre à celles de
leur parti.
Mais comment l’identification partisane
se construit-elle ? C’est l’environnement
social, tout particulièrement familial, qui
détermine les préférences politiques de
l’électeur. Du coup, le choix de l’électeur
s’explique bien plus par les influences
sociales qu’il a reçues depuis son enfance
que par sa situation socio-économique au
moment du vote (ce qui était la thèse du
modèle de l’université de Columbia).
La leçon essentielle de ce livre est donc
que le vote est plus une question de sentiment
que de raison. Les électeurs sont plus susceptibles
d'être influencés par leur affection ou
leur aversion pour un candidat ou un parti,
que par la position du candidat ou du parti
sur des questions spécifiques. Du coup, des
personnes peu intéressées par la politique
peuvent néanmoins participer aux élections,
plus par habitude que par conviction.
Ces conclusions réalistes ont des implications
importantes pour les campagnes. C’est bien
de défendre ses idées et ses propositions,
mais il sera plus efficace de créer ou de
renforcer un lien émotionnel avec l’électorat.
The American Voter a déjà eu une grande
influence théorique. Il a été un modèle
pour de nombreuses études ultérieures en
matière de recherche électorale. Il a également
lancé le débat académique sur la question
de la rationalité de l’électeur. Enfin,
il a eu le mérite de souligner l’importance
des facteurs psychologiques dans le vote.
Mais ces conclusions ont été contestées.
D’après les successeurs de l'école du
Michigan elle-même, Angus Campbell a survalorisé
l’identification partisane parce qu’il
s’est trop reposé sur les données de l'élection
présidentielle de 1956. Or, l’identification
partisane aurait été beaucoup moins forte
dans les élections suivantes.
The American Voter a également eu une influence
pratique. Il a encouragé les conseillers
et les communicants à faire appel aux sentiments
plutôt qu’à la raison des électeurs.
Comme le dit le publicitaire dans le sketch
des Inconnus, « il ne faut jamais prendre
les gens pour des cons… mais il ne faut
pas oublier qu’ils le sont ».
10ème référence : Who governs ? (1961),
Robert Dahl
En 1956, le prof de sociologie de la prestigieuse
université de Columbia Charles Wright Mills
publie un livre dont le titre sonne très
complotiste aux oreilles d’un lecteur de
2023 : The Power Elite (qu’on peut traduire
par « l’élite au pouvoir », en français).
Et le contenu est fidèle au titre, ce qui
fait le succès du livre auprès du public
(les idées « complotistes » sont par nature
virales à toutes les époques). Charles Wright
Mills affirme par exemple que, dans la démocratie
américaine, le pouvoir politique est en réalité
dans les mains d’une cinquantaine de personnes
qui circulent entre le pôle des affaires,
l’état-major militaire et le directoire
politique fédéral. Autrement dit, l’Amérique
n’est une démocratie qu’en théorie — dans
les faits, il s’agit d’une oligarchie.
Pour les universitaires de la fin des années
1950, cette thèse n’est pas sérieuse.
La réponse à cette thèse est Who governs
? de Robert Dahl. En science politique, ce
livre est la référence de la thèse dite
« de la polyarchie », selon laquelle le
pouvoir politique n’est pas monopolisé
par une minorité, mais au contraire dispersé
entre de multiples acteurs. Il est également
passé à la postérité pour l’originalité
de son approche : Robert Dahl enquête sur
les processus décisionnels dans la ville
américaine de New Haven (à une centaine
de kilomètres au nord-est de New-York). Pourquoi
cette ville ? Tout simplement parce que c’est
la ville de la prestigieuse université Yale,
dans laquelle Robert Dahl est prof.
Sur la forme, Who governs ? est un livre d’un
peu moins de 400 pages. C’est un travail
académique, mais c’est très lisible. Il
n’y a pas de jargon. On retrouve le style
direct et pragmatique des auteurs américains.
Robert Dahl écrit même à la première personne.
Le titre — une très courte question sans
terme technique, qu’on peut d’ailleurs
imaginer sortir de la bouche du citoyen américain
ordinaire — le titre est emblématique du
ton de l’auteur.
Que retenir du fond, maintenant ?
Robert Dahl affirme que le pouvoir est dispersé
dans les démocraties pluralistes : comme
je l’ai dit, c’est ce qu’on appelle
la « polyarchie » (formé à partir du grec
polus, « beaucoup », par opposition à la
monarchie, et surtout à l’oligarchie, où
un petit nombre [oligoi, en grec] détient
le pouvoir). Il ne faut pas confondre la polyarchie
avec la polyGarchie, qui est une forme de
gouvernement où plusieurs personnes ou entités
(mais sous-entendu en petit nombre) détiennent
le pouvoir. Donc une oligarchie est une forme
de polyGarchie. L’idée de la polyarchie,
en revanche, est un système où le pouvoir
politique est dispersé en de multiples centres
(c’est pour ça qu’on parle aussi de « polycentrisme
»).
Attention donc à ne pas confondre :
* la polyGarchie, lorsque plusieurs personnes
ou entités (mais qui sont peu nombreuses)
détiennent le pouvoir ;
* l’oligarchie, la même chose, mais le
terme souligne davantage le fait que les détenteurs
du pouvoir sont un petit nombre ;
* et enfin la polyArchie, lorsque le pouvoir
est dispersé en plusieurs centres.
Tenant de la polyARCHIE, Robert Dahl affirme
qu’il y a une concurrence des élites. Le
pouvoir politique n’est pas détenu par
un seul groupe social homogène, mais par
une multiplicité d’élites économiques,
administratives ou culturelles qui sont contraintes
de s’allier selon les circonstances, et
de former des compromis pour pouvoir diriger.
En ce qui concerne plus précisément la ville
de New Haven, Robert Dahl distingue plusieurs
strates historiques de dirigeants. Il y a
d’abord les familles traditionnellement
dominantes, qu’il appelle (en référence
à l’histoire romaine) les « patriciens
». Mais il y a aussi les familles émergentes,
qu’il appelle donc les « plébéiens ». Et
au sein des « plébéiens », Dahl distingue
les entrepreneurs qui se sont imposés avec
l’essor de l’industrie à la fin du XIXe
siècle ; les représentants syndicaux ou
associatifs issus des milieux populaires ; et
puis des élites d’un nouveau genre, comme
les bureaucrates et les experts.
Effectivement, la structure du pouvoir était
bien oligarchique autrefois. Mais l’émergence
des entrepreneurs, des représentants politiques
issus des milieux populaires, des bureaucrates
et des experts ont transformé la réalité
du pouvoir : New Haven est devenue une polyarchie.
Les ressources et les moyens d’influence
sont désormais répartis entre diverses élites
qui se font concurrence pour défendre leurs
intérêts. Dahl montre comment elles interviennent
dans le processus de décision dans plusieurs
enjeux municipaux comme l’urbanisme, l’enseignement
public, ou la désignation de candidats. Il
dit même que ce ne sont pas les élites qui
ont le dernier mot en pratique, mais les administrateurs
de quartier ainsi que des élus locaux de
moindre importance.
Who governs ? a été très influent en science
politique, et il l’a été à 3 égards
:
1. Ce livre fournit tout d’abord un modèle
d’étude empirique. Les équipes de Robert
Dahl ont mené des interviews détaillées
et ont participé, en tant qu’observateurs,
à des prises de décision.
2. Ce livre a ensuite transformé la perspective
de la science politique sur la question du
pouvoir. L’idée qui prédominait, c’est
que le pouvoir était concentré dans les
mains d’une minorité qui a la capacité
d’imposer sa volonté au reste de la société.
Mais Dahl montre avec l’exemple de New Haven
que le pouvoir n’est pas concentré. En
1960, soit un an avant la publication de ce
livre, notre Raymond Aron national avait déjà
écrit dans un article du Journal européen
de sociologie intitulé « Classe sociale,
classe politique, classe dirigeante » que
les élites sont en réalité traversées
par de nombreux conflits, et que c’est justement
l’intérêt de la démocratie que d’organiser
la compétition de différents groupes sociaux.
3. Enfin, troisième dimension de l’influence
de Who governs ? en science politique : ce
livre popularise les études sur la vie politique
locale. Il montre comment les hommes se gouvernent
concrètement au sein d’une communauté
complexe.
La grande influence de ce livre a fait de
Robert Dahl un des plus grands, sinon LE plus
grand politiste américain du XXe siècle.
11ème référence : Le phénomène bureaucratique
(1963), Michel Crozier
La SEITA, acronyme de « Société d'exploitation
industrielle des tabacs et des allumettes
», est l’entreprise publique qui détenait
le monopole de la production de tabac et d’allumettes
jusqu’en 1970. Pendant les Trente Glorieuses,
elle fait fonctionner 30 usines, chacune dirigée
par deux polytechniciens recrutés à la sortie
de l’école, le directeur et le directeur
adjoint. Tout obéit à des règles très
précises. Comme le directeur est essentiellement
un représentant de l’usine dans la ville
où elle est située, c’est le directeur
adjoint qui assure la direction effective
de l’activité : il applique scrupuleusement
les règlements. Et c’est la même chose
à tous les échelons : les ingénieurs appliquent
scrupuleusement les règlements ; les contrôleurs
techniques appliquent scrupuleusement les
règlements ; les chefs d’atelier se contentent
d’enregistrer le temps de travail, de peur
de se heurter au puissant syndicat CGT. Bref,
l’usine est une machine où l’initiative
n’a pas sa place.
C’est en menant une étude sociologique
dans cette entreprise ainsi qu’aux chèques
postaux (un ancien service de La Poste qui
permettait aux citoyens français qui n’avaient
pas de compte bancaire d’effectuer des transactions
financières de base) — c’est en menant
une étude sociologique dans ces deux institutions
publiques, la SEITA (les cigarettes) et les
chèques postaux, que Michel Crozier tente
de décrire scientifiquement le mécanisme
de la bureaucratie. Le livre dont accouche
son enquête, Le phénomène bureaucratique,
deviendra un classique en science politique
parce qu’il révolutionne la perspective
sur la bureaucratie. Aux yeux de Michel Crozier,
la bureaucratie n'est pas un monstre de rationalité
froide, mais un système dynamique, façonné
par les relations humaines.
Sur la forme, ce livre fait un peu moins de
400 pages. Comparé au style des sociologues
les plus jargonneux, c’est très accessible.
Le ton est impersonnel, peu chaleureux, mais
le propos a le mérite d’être clair. Même
si les paragraphes sont un peu longs, le découpage
structure efficacement le discours. Sociologue
d’abord passé par HEC, Michel Crozier accompagne
le lecteur à la première personne du pluriel
comme un étudiant qui annonce les parties
de sa dissertation à la fin de l’introduction.
Il a beau avoir été formé aux États-Unis,
son style garde quelque chose du style européen,
plus théorique, moins pragmatique que le
style des auteurs américains.
Maintenant, quelles sont les idées essentielles
de ce livre ?
La première, c’est — comme on peut s’y
attendre étant donné le titre — une redéfinition
de la bureaucratie. Max Weber en avait donné
une définition positive 40 ans plus tôt
: il voyait la bureaucratie comme l’incarnation,
au niveau de l’administration, de la rationalisation
du monde. C’est une organisation purement
rationnelle, donc suprêmement efficace. Cette
vision ne correspond pas du tout à la dimension
péjorative de notre idée de la bureaucratie,
qui évoque au contraire l’inefficacité.
La théorie de Michel Crozier est, elle, conforme
au sens commun moderne. La raison d’être
de la bureaucratie n’est pas l’efficacité,
mais la pacification des relations humaines.
En effet, les règles impersonnelles, les
routines, et la hiérarchie très détaillée
ont l’avantage de protéger les individus
des conflits. Le système bureaucratique est
particulièrement stable, comme si les luttes
de territoire, les conflits d’intérêts,
ou toutes les formes de concurrence avaient
été réglés une fois pour toutes par des
réglementations minutieuses.
Mais cette paix théorique a de gros effets
pervers. Il y a tout d’abord l’inefficacité,
c’est-à-dire l’incapacité à atteindre
l’objectif de l’activité (ce à quoi
on pourrait ajouter l’inefficience, c’est-à-dire
l’incapacité à progresser vers l’objectif
en économisant les moyens). Pourquoi la bureaucratie
est-elle si peu performante ? Parce qu’elle
ne tolère pas l’imprévu, alors qu’il
y a toujours des imprévus. Et puis parce
qu’elle repose sur une implication minimale
du personnel, d’où une faible productivité
et la médiocre qualité des biens ou services
qu’elle produit. Et enfin, le plus grave,
plus la bureaucratie dysfonctionne, plus elle
persévère dans ce qui la fait dysfonctionner.
Michel Crozier souligne un autre effet pervers
important, dont découle la deuxième idée
essentielle du livre. Malgré l’effet pacificateur
de la bureaucratie, des conflits surviennent.
Les groupes hiérarchiques s’isolent les
uns des autres, se transforment en castes,
puis entrent dans des luttes de pouvoir les
uns contre les autres. Ces luttes sont liées
à ce que Crozier appelle des « zones d’incertitude
», des zones non couvertes par l’organisation
formelle. À l’échelle de l’individu,
l’enjeu est de maîtriser sa zone d’incertitude,
car celle-ci donne une marge de manœuvre,
une faculté de recourir à des ressources
stratégiques pour accroître son pouvoir
et son autonomie. À la SEITA, par exemple,
les pannes de machine constituent une zone
d’incertitude pour la maîtrise de laquelle
s’opposent les ouvriers de production et
les ouvriers d’entretien.
La dernière idée essentielle du livre est
la dimension culturelle de la bureaucratie.
Michel Crozier estime que c’est une forme
d’organisation qui semble bien correspondre
à la mentalité française. La résistance
au changement serait un trait propre de l’Histoire
de France. En matière économique, le pays
a laissé s’épanouir un capitalisme bourgeois
essentiellement familial, valorisant fortement
le prestige social, et en cela averse au risque,
et donc hostile à l’innovation. Si elle
paralyse la société, la bureaucratie serait
adaptée à l’originalité du peuple français,
à la fois peu démocratique et très individualiste.
Du coup, Michel Crozier anticipe que la bureaucratie
française ne pourra probablement pas être
transformée de manière incrémentale, mais
par crises successives.
Le phénomène bureaucratique n’est certes
pas un des plus grands classiques de la science
politique, mais il est une référence incontournable
concernant la bureaucratie.
C’est là la 1ère dimension de son influence
: il a dirigé la réflexion vers un thème
de plus en plus important en Occident avec
le développement de l’État providence.
La 2nde dimension de son influence en science
politique est la revalorisation du rôle des
acteurs par rapport à celui des institutions.
Pour le dire simplement, une organisation
n’est pas un système auquel l’individu
se soumet passivement ; c’est un système
façonné par les relations humaines parce
que les hommes se servent des règles pour
faire prévaloir leurs intérêts. « Nous
rejetons trop facilement nos difficultés,
écrit Michel Crozier, sur des épouvantails
abstraits comme le progrès, la technique,
la bureaucratie. Ce ne sont pas les techniques
ou les formes d'organisation qui sont coupables.
Ce sont les hommes qui, consciemment ou inconsciemment,
participent à leur élaboration. » La perspective
originale du livre sera à l’origine de
la sociologie des organisations en France.
Pour finir, même si ce n’est pas ce pour
quoi il est passé à la postérité, ce livre
est aussi très intéressant pour ce qu’il
dit du style de vie français. En étudiant
la bureaucratie française, Michel Crozier
met en évidence un rapport typiquement français
à l’existence qui semble imperméable au
temps. Il caractérise ce rapport français
à l’existence par une grande indépendance
personnelle et une grande lucidité intellectuelle,
et il estime que cet esprit original a enrichi
la civilisation occidentale.
12ème référence : La logique de l'action
collective (1965), Mancur Olson
Le grand syndicat médical American Medical
Association est particulièrement efficace
pour obtenir l’adhésion des médecins qui
exercent aux États-Unis. Mais il n’est
pas partisan de la méthode douce. Si un médecin
néglige de cotiser, il perd le soutien des
avocats du syndicat, et il peut même en être
la victime ! L’Américain Mancur Olson montre
que ce type de pression est nécessaire pour
que l’individu s’investisse dans une grande
organisation.
Son livre La logique de l'action collective
est une référence incontournable en science
politique sur le thème de l’action collective.
Mancur Olson est économiste et sociologue,
mais la théorie qu’il développe dans ce
livre est très utile pour comprendre de nombreux
phénomènes sociaux et politiques, dont notamment
l’abstention, la mobilisation politique,
ou encore l’activité des syndicats et des
groupes de pression. Il dit d’ailleurs lui-même
dès le premier paragraphe de l’introduction
que la question qu’il va traiter concerne
à la fois l’économie, la science politique
et la sociologie.
Sur la forme, c’est un petit livre. Il sera
pourtant certainement une corvée pour le
lecteur amateur. Certains sociologues font
pire sur le plan du jargon, et les paragraphes
ne sont pas non plus interminables, mais le
propos, et donc le style de Mancur Olson sont
beaucoup trop théoriques (d’ailleurs 4
parties du livre sur 6 contiennent le mot
« théorie » dans leur titre). Il enchaîne
parfois les paragraphes sans un seul exemple
concret, alors qu’en l’occurrence il serait
très facile d’en donner et de rendre la
démonstration plus vivante. En plus, les
phrases sont souvent longues, ce qui rend
la lecture d’autant plus pénible. Mais
bon, c’est un livre écrit par un universitaire
pour les universitaires : c’est une adaptation
de la thèse de doctorat d’Olson à Harvard,
et le livre est même publié par la maison
d’édition de Harvard.
Que retenir du fond ?
Mancur Olson dissipe le fantasme de l’action
collective. Influencé par la mythologie révolutionnaire
(notamment), on s’imagine que les membres
d’un groupe agissent comme un seul homme
vers leur but commun. Seulement, contrairement
à ce qu'affirme Marx, la communauté d'intérêt
ne suffit pas à provoquer l'action commune
permettant de promouvoir l'intérêt de tous.
Dans une démocratie représentative, par
exemple, la société a intérêt à ce que
les citoyens votent pour choisir les gouvernants
— et pourtant une partie non négligeable
des électeurs s’abstiennent.
Comment l’expliquer ? Eh bien l’individu
ne se fond pas dans le groupe, il conserve
toujours sa rationalité à lui. Mancur Olson
admet que les individus se rassemblent afin
de poursuivre des objectifs qu’ils sont
incapables d’atteindre seuls, mais il explique
que l’individu ne passe pas pour autant
à l’action. En effet, il y a une discordance
entre la rationalité individuelle et la rationalité
collective. Pour déterminer s’il doit s’investir
ou non, l’individu met en balance le coût
et l’avantage qu’il peut en retirer. Ce
calcul coût-bénéfice individuel devrait
enrayer l’action collective. En effet, la
stratégie la plus rationnelle pour un membre
est celle du « passager clandestin » (« free
rider » en anglais), qui consiste à tenter
de tirer un bénéfice de l’action collective
sans en supporter les coûts (au sens propre,
le passager clandestin bénéficie du transport
sans contribuer, comme les autres passagers,
au coût du transport).
Cette stratégie a beau être la plus rationnelle,
l’action collective a pourtant lieu. Tel
est le paradoxe de l’action collective souligné
par Mancur Olson.
Comment expliquer ce paradoxe ? Eh bien les
groupes font comme l’American Medical Association
: ils motivent le passage à l’action des
membres par des incitations sélectives qui
discriminent les participants des non-participants.
Ces incitations peuvent être matérielles
(comme de l’argent, des emplois, des postes
de pouvoir [comme dans les partis politiques])
ou symboliques (comme un statut particulier)
; elles peuvent être positives, mais aussi
négatives (par exemple, un médecin qui ne
cotise plus à l’American Medical Association
perd la sécurité juridique). Un exemple
célèbre d’incitation sélective est le
système du closed shop, en vertu duquel les
syndicats ont le monopole à l’embauche
(créé aux États-Unis au début du XXe siècle
pour renforcer le pouvoir des syndicats, il
a ensuite été interdit pour que les travailleurs
aient la liberté de choisir).
Si les incitations sélectives rendent possible
l’action collective, elles n’annulent
pas les stratégies individuelles. Celles-ci
continuent d’empoisonner la coopération.
De ce problème découle une vérité essentielle
sur l’action collective : plus un groupe
humain est grand, moins il est enclin à passer
à l’action. Mancur Olson montre que les
petits groupes sont bien plus efficaces. En
effet, le bénéfice individuel est bien plus
élevé ; la pression sociale est plus forte
(chacun pousse les autres à participer) ; et
l’organisation est moins compliquée et
moins coûteuse. Olson estime que c’est
pour cette raison que les minorités sont
influentes en démocratie. « Les groupes
les plus petits, écrit-il, réussissent souvent
à battre les plus grands qui, dans une démocratie,
seraient naturellement censés l’emporter.
» Son analyse crédibilise plus généralement
l’idée que ce sont les petits groupes — et
non pas les masses, comme le pose le marxisme
— qui font l’histoire. Marx se désolait
qu’une partie des ouvriers anglais continuent
de voter pour les conservateurs, c’est pourquoi
Lénine affirmait la nécessité d’une élite
organisatrice au sein du prolétariat.
Comment expliquer l’influence de La logique
de l'action collective en science politique
?
Pour faire simple, c’est le livre de référence
du nouveau paradigme d’interprétation de
la mobilisation des masses. Mancur Olson montre
en revenant au niveau de l’acteur individuel
que la logique de l’action collective est
bien plus compliquée que ce que disent les
théories qui parlent d’un grand groupe
humain — le peuple ou le prolétariat, par
exemple — comme d’un acteur individuel
avec une volonté unique. Le paradoxe qu’il
souligne éclaire bien le fait que le soutien,
l’adhésion verbale à une cause (par exemple)
ne garantit pas du tout le passage à l’action.
« Talk is cheap » dit l’adage américain
(on pourrait le traduire en français par
« les paroles ne coûtent rien »).
Ce livre n’est pas le dernier mot sur la
question, mais Olson pose le cadre des efforts
théoriques ultérieurs. Ceux-ci approfondiront
notamment la dimension psychologique de l’action
collective, un peu négligée par Olson.
13ème référence : Démocratie et totalitarisme
(1965), Raymond Aron
Ce livre est paru en 1965, mais il est constitué
de cours professés à la Sorbonne durant
l'année universitaire 1957-1958. Or, entre-temps,
il s’est passé… l’instauration de la
Ve République par le général de Gaulle.
Du coup, Raymond Aron donne son avis dans
l’introduction. Il qualifie le passage au
nouveau régime de « révolution pacifique
et semi-légale ». Il dit carrément que
c’est un retour à l’Empire. La Ve République
est plus précisément un empire parlementaire
dans lequel la personne du chef de l’État
— c’est encore le général de Gaulle
lorsqu’Aron écrit cette introduction — la
personne du chef de l’État est plus importante
que le texte de la Constitution dans le fonctionnement
du régime.
Raymond Aron dit cela pour justifier le fait
que le régime original qu’est la Ve République
ne rentre pas dans le cadre de ses analyses.
S’il a besoin de se justifier, c’est parce
que ce livre donne une théorie générale
des régimes politiques — or, moins d’un
an après qu’il a élaboré sa théorie
naît un nouveau régime, un régime inédit,
en considération duquel sa belle théorie
risque de périmer ! Démocratie et totalitarisme
deviendra tout de même une référence incontournable
en science politique. C’est un classique
à Sciences Po et dans les facultés. C’est
le premier livre que j’ai fiché pour mon
Master de philosophie politique à la Sorbonne.
Effectivement, le propos se situe à l'intersection
de la philosophie politique et de la science
politique. D’un côté, il y a des éléments
de réflexion abstraite sur les concepts fondamentaux
du pouvoir, de l'autorité et du gouvernement
; de l’autre côté, Aron s’appuie sur
des données empiriques, des faits historiques,
et il mène une analyse comparative des régimes
politiques en étudiant comment ils fonctionnent
dans le monde réel.
Sur la forme, Démocratie et totalitarisme
est un livre d’un peu moins de 400 pages,
plutôt dense à la lecture. Aron est renommé
pour la clarté de son propos, ce qui fait
que les étudiants l’aiment beaucoup et
conservent un bon souvenir de ses livres.
Cependant, il faut reconnaître que divers
facteurs compliquent tout de même la lecture
: les paragraphes et les phrases sont parfois
longs ; le vocabulaire peut dérouter par
sa technicité ; les références historiques,
quoique pertinentes et présentées clairement,
peuvent perdre le lecteur — et certainement
davantage celui des années 2020 que celui
des années 1960. Après, le propos demeure
étonnamment clair en considération de sa
profondeur. Et je suis personnellement séduit
— comme beaucoup de lecteurs — par l’humilité
intellectuelle et l’antidogmatisme d’Aron.
C’est autre chose que Sartre.
Quel est l’essentiel sur le fond, maintenant
?
Raymond Aron a choisi le titre Démocratie
et totalitarisme parce que ces deux formes
politiques constituent l’antithèse de la
philosophie politique. Or, cette antithèse
est révélatrice à plusieurs égards. Elle
montre que la politique est plus importante
que l’économie dans le destin collectif.
Elle montre également qu’il n’existe
pas de vie sociale sans autorité organisée,
et plus précisément que le style de l’autorité
est caractéristique des relations sociales
(autrement dit, comme le disait déjà Platon
dans La République, il y a un lien entre
les valeurs, les mentalités et le régime
politique).
Aron développe son propos à partir de cette
base.
Il parle tout d’abord du régime politique.
Les auteurs de référence en la matière,
Aristote et Montesquieu, distinguent tous
les deux les types de régimes politiques
en fonction du nombre de détenteurs du pouvoir,
mais les régimes reflètent aussi une certaine
conception de la nature humaine et du pouvoir.
Sur quels critères choisir un régime politique
? Il doit être légitime — c’est-à-dire
que les gouvernés pensent que le détenteur
du pouvoir mérite le pouvoir — et efficace
— c’est-à-dire qu’il permet d’atteindre
les objectifs. Ainsi, le problème politique
consiste fondamentalement à justifier l’obéissance.
Le droit le fait par le concept de souveraineté,
la philosophie politique par l’égalité
et les libertés. En pratique, les régimes
des pays occidentaux légitiment l’obéissance
par la concurrence pacifique pour l’exercice
du pouvoir, à travers les élections — à
travers ce mécanisme, le destin de la collectivité
est pris en charge par la collectivité elle-même.
Mais Aron estime que « l’essence même
de la politique est que des décisions soient
prises pour, non par, la collectivité ».
La question de la légitimité du régime
conduit à celle de sa potentielle corruption.
Aron distingue trois espèces de corruption
: celle des institutions politiques ; celle
de l’esprit public ; et enfin celle de l’infrastructure
sociale, lorsque l’organisation des interactions
individuelles dysfonctionne. Une autre classification
est possible, en distinguant une tendance
à l’oligarchie et une tendance à la démagogie.
Après, un régime politique n’est pas forcément
condamné à long terme. Pour Aron, le long
terme crée de la vulnérabilité, mais peut-être
aussi un renforcement par la durée. La corruption
est l’argument traditionnel des adversaires
irréductibles des démocraties.
L’antithèse entre la démocratie et le
totalitarisme permet de mieux comprendre la
question du régime politique, mais quelle
est la différence fondamentale entre ces
deux pôles ? Pour Aron, c’est la constitutionnalité
— c’est-à-dire le fait que le pouvoir
politique repose sur un socle de règles fondamentales
inviolables — et le pluralisme, c’est-à-dire
la coexistence de diverses opinions au sein
de la société. Du coup, Aron appelle les
démocraties occidentales « régimes constitutionnels
pluralistes ». Les régimes ni constitutionnels
ni pluralistes, en revanche, ne sont pas tous
totalitaires. Aron définit le totalitarisme
par cinq caractéristiques : 1° un parti
monopolistique ; 2° une idéologie vérité
officielle de l’État ; 3° un monopole
des moyens pour l’État ; 4° l’omniprésence
de l’État ; 5° la terreur policière et
idéologique. De ce point de vue, le communisme
et le national-socialisme avaient des pratiques
équivalentes.
Comment résumer l’influence de ce livre
en science politique ? Sur le plan des idées,
il est une des références modernes, sinon
la référence moderne sur le thème des systèmes
politiques. Il est aussi, en termes de perspective
intellectuelle, le livre le plus emblématique
du fait que la philosophie politique demeure
intéressante pour la science politique ; et
de l’intérêt de mêler les deux disciplines
pour traiter des questions politiques fondamentales
avec une approche à la fois profonde et moderne,
théorique et empirique. Enfin, comme je l’ai
dit au début, l’influence de Démocratie
et totalitarisme tient également au fait
qu’il est devenu un livre phare de l’enseignement
de la science politique.
14ème référence : Why Men Rebel? (1970),
Ted Robert Gurr
L’historien Georges Lefebvre ouvre son livre
La grande peur de 1789 (à propos de la panique
qui se répand en France à l’été 1789,
peu après le début de la Révolution française)
— il ouvre son livre en parlant de l’état
du peuple français à cette époque. Il évoque
notamment la misérable condition des ouvriers
des villes, la « canaille » urbaine. Cette
masse de prolétaires inquiétaient les administrateurs
des grandes villes de l’hexagone, surtout
à Paris. Les autorités craignaient une révolte
au moindre renchérissement du pain. Et d’après
le politologue américain Ted Robert Gurr,
cette crainte était justifiée.
Publié à la fin des Trente Glorieuses, Why
Men Rebel? (qu’on peut traduire en français
par « Pourquoi les hommes se rebellent-ils
? ») est une référence incontournable sur
le thème de la violence politique. La thèse
que Ted Robert Gurr y développe est devenue
un modèle de compréhension de l’action
collective en science politique.
Dans son édition la plus récente, Why Men
Rebel? est un livre d’environ 450 pages.
Le propos est moyennement accessible. D’un
côté, Ted Robert Gurr verse peu dans le
jargon — il prévient dans l’introduction
qu’il puisera dans toutes les sciences humaines
— les phrases ne sont pas trop longues,
leurs structures pas trop compliquées, et
on retrouve globalement le style pragmatique
des auteurs américains ; mais de l’autre
côté, ce style pêche par son abstraction
et son académisme — Gurr donne l’impression
de s’adresser à ses pairs, et non au lecteur
profane. Enfin, les paragraphes sont souvent
longs.
Maintenant, quelle est la fameuse thèse de
ce livre ?
Gurr estime que les théories sur la violence
politique sont inutilement compliquées. C’est
un thème si ancien, si observé et étudié
à travers le monde que nous en oublions des
facteurs psychologiques et sociaux de base.
Il faut donc simplifier le problème.
Comment Gurr s’y prend-il ? Il met en évidence
un facteur à ses yeux essentiel dans la violence
politique, qu’il baptise la « frustration
relative » (« relative deprivation » en
anglais). La frustration, c’est le fait
d’avoir un désir qu’on ne peut pas satisfaire
(par exemple, je me rends à la boulangerie
pour acheter un éclair à la vanille, mais
la boulangerie vient de fermer). C’est un
état psychologique désagréable. Gurr parle,
lui, d’une frustration relative pour désigner
l’écart perçu négativement par les individus
entre, d’une part, les biens qu’ils se
sentent autorisés à convoiter, et d’autre
part ceux qu’ils obtiennent effectivement.
S’ils obtiennent bien moins que ce qu’ils
pensent mériter, alors la frustration grandit.
Leurs attentes sont souvent matérielles (le
salaire, la protection sociale, etc.), mais
elles peuvent aussi être politiques (comme
le dit Aristote dans Les politiques, les hommes
veulent avoir le sentiment de participer au
pouvoir) ; les attentes peuvent encore être
hiérarchiques (le statut), ou encore identitaires.
D’après Gurr, plus les types d’attentes
se combinent, plus la frustration est marquée.
Dans le détail, la frustration est relative
à 3 paramètres : 1° à la situation ; 2°
à un autre groupe social ; 3° à l’époque.
Le rapport entre les attentes et la réalité
varie donc beaucoup. Par exemple, les attentes
des paysans de l’Ancien Régime qui meurent
de faim sont bien moins élevées que les
attentes des gilets jaunes qui se révoltent
à la fin 2018 — mais la frustration relative
est comparable. C’est fondamentalement la
logique du désir humain. Les philosophes
de l’Antiquité avaient déjà mis en lumière
ce que les scientifiques redécouvrent au
début du XXIe siècle en étudiant la dopamine
: l’homme ne satisfait pas ses désirs dans
l’absolu, mais par rapport à un niveau
de base qui évolue selon son expérience
; plus il satisfait ses désirs, comme l’individu
occidental moderne, plus ses attentes sont
élevées ; plus sa condition est difficile,
comme le paysan de l’Ancien Régime qui
meurt de faim, plus ses attentes sont basses.
C’est donc le niveau de base de satisfaction
qui change — la frustration, elle, n’est
pas sensiblement différente du révolté
du XVIIIe siècle à celui du XXIe siècle.
Le risque de violence politique survient lorsque
le décalage entre les attentes et la réalité
est trop grand. Alors, si les individus frustrés
se rassemblent, et sous certaines conditions,
leur frustration peut se transformer en une
colère visant les responsables supposés
de cette frustration. La violence sociale
devient politique lorsqu’elle s’attaque
au régime politique. Cependant, ce changement
de nature n’est pas automatique. Pour qu’il
s’opère, il est nécessaire que la résistance
au régime apparaisse comme légitime et que
le recours à la violence apparaisse nécessaire
pour obtenir des résultats (s’il paraît
efficace, alors il peut se répandre par contagion
mimétique).
Mais le pouvoir n’est pas impuissant. Il
peut contribuer à rendre la violence moins
justifiée en mettant en avant le soutien
de la population et des institutions. Sur
le plan pratique, il peut rendre la violence
moins efficace avec des techniques de maintien
de l’ordre (comme dans les démocraties)
ou en réprimant violemment les révoltes
(comme dans les dictatures).
Quelle est l’influence de ce livre en science
politique ? Pour faire simple, c’est la
référence sur le thème de la violence.
Publié pour la première fois en 1970 après
une décennie de violence politique à travers
le monde, il a été réédité en 2015 parce
que la thèse de la frustration relative est
toujours pertinente pour expliquer les révoltes
du début du XXIe siècle (Gurr évoque les
révoltes arabes du tournant des années 2010
dans son introduction à la nouvelle édition).
Enfin, Why Men Rebel? illustre également
l’utilité de la science politique pour
les enjeux de sécurité. Sa théorie a beau
être empirique, Gurr dit qu’elle n’a
pas vocation à être mise en pratique. Mais
comme il anticipe qu’elle risque de servir
tant aux révoltés qu’aux autorités, il
précise dans l’introduction qu’il n’est
pas responsable de ce que les acteurs politiques
en feront.
Vous aimez les gros manuels ?
Je sais bien, c’est pas une partie de plaisir.
Mais comment faire si vous voulez découvrir
les idées d’Aristote, par exemple ?
Eh bien allez sur le site 1000 idées de culture
générale.
Vous tapez « Aristote » dans la barre de
recherche, et vous avez les synthèses, des
synthèses très claires des meilleures idées
d’Aristote.
Rédigées avec amour et beaucoup de café,
par votre serviteur.
Et comme le nom l’indique, 1000 idées de
culture générale ce n’est pas que de la
philo.
Vous trouverez aussi les meilleures idées
en économie, en littérature, en histoire,
en science politique, en psychologie, etc.
Alors maintenant, que faire de ces gros manuels
?
Alors moi je les garde, parce qu’ils sont
bien pratiques pour remplir la bibliothèque
quand je tourne des vidéos.
Mais vous, vous pouvez vous en servir comme
support pour poser la casserole, ou bien pour
faire de la musculation, si vous n’aimez
pas les haltères classiques.
[Moi en train de soulever de gros manuels]
« C’est moins fatiguant que de les lire
! ».
Vous n’avez pas besoin de vous prendre la
tête pour découvrir le meilleur de la pensée.
Allez simplement sur le site 1000 idées de
culture générale.
15ème référence : The changing American
Voter (1976), Norman Nie, Sidney Verba, et
John Petrocik
Une étude menée sur les élections qui ont
eu lieu au Royaume-Uni entre 1965 et 1980
estime que deux tiers des électeurs ont changé
plusieurs fois leurs choix partisans au cours
de la période. Ce résultat étonnant illustre
un nouveau phénomène : la volatilité électorale.
Du coup, les théories qui expliquent le choix
des électeurs par les spécificités de leur
région, par l’influence de la famille,
par des variables sociales, ou encore par
un attachement affectif durable — ces théories
qui élucidaient la stabilité du vote semblent
désormais périmées.
C’est pour cette raison que le titre de
ce livre, The changing American voter, est
un clin d’œil à la 9ème référence de
ma liste, The American Voter d’Angus Campbell.
C’est la référence en science politique
sur le thème de la volatilité électorale.
C’est un travail empirique qui repose sur
les enquêtes électorales menées au cours
des années 50 et 60 par le Survey Research
Center de l’université du Michigan. Je
fais apparaître uniquement Norman Nie, qui
était chercheur en sciences sociales à Stanford,
à l’écran — mais il a pour coauteurs
son mentor Sidney Verba, qui était prof de
science politique à Harvard, et John Petrocik,
lui aussi prof de science politique, mais
à l’université du Missouri (un état du
centre des États-Unis).
Sur le plan de la forme, c’est un livre
de 430 pages écrit en petits caractères.
Le style a les défauts d’un travail universitaire
: les paragraphes sont parfois longs ; le
langage est parfois technique (même si ce
n’est pas toujours le cas) ; le ton est
formel. En revanche, les auteurs ont le mérite
de clarifier le débat en évoquant les précédents
travaux de référence sur la question du
vote. Mais leur effort de rigueur rend la
lecture globalement pénible pour l’amateur.
L’analyse détaillée des résultats des
enquêtes n’est pas passionnante.
Maintenant, quel est l’essentiel à retenir
concernant ce livre ?
Le point de départ de la réflexion des auteurs
est que les électeurs américains de la fin
des Trente Glorieuses sont bien différents
de ceux du début de la période. « Tout
comme la politique a changé, écrivent-ils,
le public a également évolué en réponse
à ce changement. Le public américain du
milieu des années soixante-dix diffère fondamentalement
du public des années cinquante » (c’est
moi qui ai traduit).
Qu’est-ce qui a changé au niveau du vote
? Le choix de l’électeur n’est plus une
question d’identification partisane (comme
l’affirmait Angus Campbell 15 ans plus tôt
dans The American Voter). Le phénomène déterminant
est désormais le « vote sur enjeux ». Autrement
dit, l’électeur considère les grandes
questions politiques du moment (par exemple,
le chômage ou l’insécurité), et il donne
sa voix au candidat dont la position sur ces
grandes questions lui plaît. Il voterait
donc davantage pour des idées.
Cette nouvelle attitude par rapport au vote
est en partie liée à l’histoire des États-Unis.
En effet, le pays connaissait une crise politique
dans les années 1960, avec les protestations
contre la guerre du Vietnam, le mouvement
des droits civiques, les émeutes urbaines,
les assassinats de personnalités politiques
telles que John F. Kennedy, Malcolm X et Martin
Luther King, ou encore l’émergence de l’écologie.
Mais le vote sur enjeu résulte plus globalement
de l’évolution des mentalités occidentales.
L’individu est plus autonome ; il pense
davantage par lui-même, et de manière plus
rationnelle. Il est également plus individualiste,
ce qui le rend sensible aux promesses susceptibles
d’améliorer sa situation personnelle. Par
conséquent, il préfère étudier les programmes,
et il le fait dans un esprit d’indépendance
par rapport aux partis.
Quelles sont les racines du vote sur enjeux
? Les auteurs en soulignent deux principales.
La première racine est que les enjeux politiques
sont plus saillants à partir de la fin des
Trente Glorieuses (ce qui tient aux événements
eux-mêmes, mais également à une médiatisation
accrue des événements [la popularité de
la télévision a explosé au cours des années
1960 aux États-Unis]). La seconde racine
est la démocratisation de l’enseignement.
En effet, des électeurs plus instruits sont
moins fidèles aux organisations partisanes.
The changing American Voter a marqué la science
politique pour 3 raisons :
1. En premier lieu, c’est un modèle sur
le plan de la méthode de travail. Les auteurs
ont analysé minutieusement une grande quantité
de données, et cela donne un crédit scientifique
à leurs conclusions.
2. En deuxième lieu, leurs conclusions renversent
la perspective sur le thème du comportement
électoral. Le citoyen ne vote pas par habitude
; il fait un choix rationnel après s’être
informé. Les générations ultérieures de
politistes reprocheront à ce livre de surestimer
la rationalité de l’électeur, donc certains
corrigeront le tir (15 ans plus tard sortira
un livre intitulé The Reasoning Voter, qui
reprend la perspective de The changing American
Voter, mais avec une hypothèse de rationalité
plus réaliste selon laquelle l’électeur
réfléchit en faisant des raccourcis).
3. Enfin, la troisième raison de l’influence
de ce livre en science politique est qu’il
explique comment la profonde transformation
de la société occidentale (américaine,
en l’occurrence) des années 1960 a transformé
la psychologie de l’électeur.
16ème référence : La révolution silencieuse
(1977), Ronald Inglehart
Sur la route de Jack Kerouac était un de
mes romans préférés à la fin de l’adolescence.
Comme beaucoup de lecteurs, j’étais fasciné
par la liberté qui se dégageait du voyage
de l’auteur et de son meilleur ami à travers
les États-Unis et le Mexique. Ce livre a
préfiguré la révolution culturelle des
années 1960 parce que ses héros sont de
jeunes Occidentaux qui sacrifient leur confort
matériel pour vivre des expériences significatives.
C’est à cette évolution des valeurs occidentales
que renvoie le beau, mais peu original titre
de ce livre, La révolution silencieuse (l’idée
de ce titre, c’est qu’une révolution
des valeurs ne se manifeste pas par des événements
concrets, donc ne fait pas de bruit). Ce livre
est incontournable en science politique parce
qu’il est l’explication de référence
concernant la révolution culturelle des Trente
Glorieuses. Il s’agit bien de science politique
— et non pas d’un simple essai — parce
que Ronald Inglehart appuie son analyse sur
une grande quantité de données, et en particulier
des enquêtes de masse qui lui permettent
d’apporter des preuves de l’évolution
des valeurs (il ne sent pas l’air du temps
au doigt mouillé).
Sur la forme, c’est un livre de 400 pages
moyennement accessible. Le style est clair
; les paragraphes sont bien structurés, et
pas interminables. Cependant, le ton est académique
(Ronald Inglehart écrit à la première personne
du pluriel) ; le langage est technique, parfois
presque jargonneux ; et l’analyse rigoureuse
détaillée des résultats des enquêtes ne
peut plaire qu’aux autres politistes, pas
au grand public.
Quel est l’essentiel à retenir de ce livre
?
La révolution silencieuse lance la théorie
qu’Inglehart approfondira dans d’autres
livres, la théorie dite la « transition
culturelle ». C’est la même idée que
celle de l’expression de « révolution
culturelle » qui s’est imposée dans l’opinion
publique, à la nuance qu’une transition
suggère un changement plus progressif et
plus long (et effectivement, on ne change
pas les valeurs d’une civilisation comme
un fait un coup d’État). Les hippies, les
révoltes étudiantes, le mouvement pour les
droits civiques, etc. sont des manifestations
d’une évolution plus profonde au niveau
des valeurs des populations occidentales,
c’est-à-dire de la hiérarchie des choses
qui comptent à leurs yeux et qui déterminent
leur rapport à l’existence et leur style
de vie.
Qu’est-ce qui a changé précisément au
niveau des valeurs ? En s’appuyant sur une
étude comparative des systèmes d’attitudes
et de hiérarchies de valeurs dans six pays
d’Europe occidentale, Inglehart constate
une révolution à partir des premières générations
du baby-boom, dès la fin des années 1940.
Il estime que la société occidentale est
devenue post-matérialiste. Ses citoyens vivent
en sécurité et mangent à leur faim, donc
— conformément à la pyramide des besoins
de Maslow (citée par Inglehart) — les Occidentaux
se mettent à désirer d’autres choses,
des choses qu’ils ne trouvent pas dans les
supermarchés. Inglehart simplifie en disant
qu’ils cherchent désormais la qualité
de vie.
Mais comment l’expliquer ? Pour Inglehart,
la cause profonde est psychologique : un adulte
désire ce qu’il n’avait pas lors de son
enfance. Or, si les générations qui n’ont
pas connu la Seconde Guerre mondiale ont grandi
dans le confort matériel, elles n’ont pas
connu le confort psychologique associé à
la focalisation sur la quête des ressources
matérielles.
Et on arrive là à la conséquence politique
de la « révolution silencieuse » : la vie
politique change progressivement dans l’ensemble
du monde occidental. Les nouvelles générations
ne se satisfont plus du modèle de société
reposant sur la croissance économique. Leurs
attentes politiques se déplacent notamment
vers des enjeux identitaires (comme dans le
mouvement des droits civiques ou dans le féminisme)
et vers des enjeux environnementaux. Inglehart
ajoute que les nouvelles générations, plus
instruites, ont également une meilleure compétence
politique, ce qui leur permet de s’impliquer
davantage dans la prise de décision.
La révolution silencieuse est important en
science politique à 3 égards :
1. Il met en valeur un thème novateur, les
valeurs de la population. Ça revient un peu
à parler dans une perspective moins philosophique
de ce qu’on appelle en philosophie politique
l’idéologie ou la « métapolitique », c’est-à-dire
les idées qui prédominent dans les esprits
des électeurs et à travers lesquelles ils
voient le monde (et bien sûr ces idées conditionnent
leurs choix politiques).
2. La révolution silencieuse est également
important sur le plan de la méthode. En effet,
il est emblématique d’une approche spéciale
en science politique qui s’appelle la « politique
comparative » (« comparative politics » en
anglais). Le principe de cette approche est,
comme son nom le suggère, de comparer les
systèmes politiques, les institutions, les
processus et les acteurs dans différents
pays.
3. Enfin, ce livre est un des quelques exemples
de prédiction réussie en science politique.
Inglehart avait prédit que le changement
intergénérationnel dans les valeurs des
populations industrielles avancées allait
transformer la vie politique, et c’est bien
ce qui s’est passé à la fin du XXe siècle.
17ème référence : Le Cens caché (1978),
Daniel Gaxie
Il y a une dizaine d’années, j’avais
été frappé en lisant un argument de Noam
Chomsky dans Comprendre le pouvoir. C’est
à propos de l’incompétence politique,
c’est-à-dire de l’idée que les citoyens
ne seraient pas intellectuellement compétents
pour prendre des décisions concernant le
destin collectif. Chomsky donne un exemple
concret : à la radio, après un match de
baseball, aux États-Unis, le commentateur
invite un auditeur à donner son avis sur
le match ; et l’avis est souvent étonnamment
approfondi : l’auditeur connaît toutes
les règles, tous les acteurs, etc. ; il évoque
l’influence de divers facteurs sur le résultat
du match — bref, son diagnostic témoignage
d’une véritable maîtrise intellectuelle
de la complexité de la situation. Il est
compétent pour donner un avis éclairé parce
qu’il s’est formé lui-même en s’intéressant
au baseball. Pourquoi, demande alors Chomsky,
ne ferait-il pas de même pour la politique
?
Daniel Gaxie donne un élément de réponse
dans Le Cens caché. Issu du verbe latin censere,
« évaluer la fortune et le rang de chacun
», le cens est un filtre qui permet de réserver
les droits politiques à certains citoyens.
Ce filtre est le plus souvent financier — il
faut avoir tel niveau de fortune, ou bien
être propriétaire, ce qui est notamment
mesurable par le paiement de l’impôt (comme
c’était le cas en France au début du XIXe
siècle) — mais le filtre du cens peut aussi
être « capacitaire », c’est-à-dire en
pratique qu’il faut avoir tel niveau d’éducation
ou bien exercer certaines professions (la
Belgique a par exemple réservé le vote [à
la fin du XIXe siècle] à certaines professions
témoignant de capacités intellectuelles
supposées [magistrats, notaires, officiers…]).
Le cens n’existe plus dans les démocraties
modernes, mais l’idée du titre est que,
dans les faits, une partie de la population
est toujours exclue du jeu démocratique.
Seulement, le phénomène est invisible.
Le Cens caché est un livre d’un peu plus
de 250 pages. Il n’est pas très agréable
à lire. Le style est impersonnel et théorique,
mais les références à la vie politique
française rendent le propos plus dynamique.
La proportion de citations paraît parfois
excessive.
Maintenant, quel est l’essentiel à retenir
sur le fond ?
La thèse de Daniel Gaxie est que le sentiment
de compétence politique a le même effet
qu’un cens (telle est l’idée du titre).
Les citoyens qui s’estiment incompétents
s’intéressent moins à la politique — on
parle d’une moindre « politisation » — et
ces citoyens participent également moins
à politique (ils votent moins notamment).
En clair, c’est de l’autocensure.
Comment l’expliquer ? C’est d’abord
une question d’éducation. En effet, les
professionnels de la politique produisent
des symboles que les citoyens apprennent à
déchiffrer à l’école. Il est possible
de l’apprendre par le seul intérêt — comme
le fan de baseball de Chomsky — ou par la
pratique, par l’action politique — mais
les privilégiés du système scolaire refusent
d’admettre que tout le monde peut être
compétent en politique. Le système actuel
contribue par là à la perpétuation des
inégalités. Daniel Gaxie plaide donc pour
la généralisation d’un enseignement politique
qui développe la compétence politique de
la population.
Mais le système politique lui-même est aussi
responsable. Certes, l’indifférence politique
recule lors de périodes de politisation telles
que les élections présidentielles en France.
La participation est cependant biaisée. En
réalité, les rituels démocratiques cantonnent
la majorité des citoyens dans un rôle de
spectateurs. Ils imposent les problématiques
et favorisent, notamment par l’influence
des commentateurs, les opinions socialement
légitimes. Du coup, les citoyens habituellement
les plus indifférents ne creusent pas ; ils
se limitent aux aspects les plus immédiats
et les plus personnalisés de l’élection.
En fait, le cens caché perpétue la domination
sociale. Daniel Gaxie met en évidence le
fait que, dans tous les pays occidentaux,
les citoyens les plus favorisés — concrètement,
les hommes âgés des classes supérieures
— sont ceux qui se sentent les plus légitimes
pour s’intéresser à la politique et s’y
impliquer. Le personnel politique est, quel
que soit le parti, sélectionné parmi les
catégories culturellement privilégiées.
Les classes populaires, elles, tiennent des
discours empruntés. En définitive, les schémas
de pensée des dominants structurent la compétition
politique, si bien que l’existence du champ
politique, avec ses pratiques et ses symboles,
suffit à reproduire la hiérarchie sociale.
Daniel Gaxie en conclut que la démocratie
en politique est la même chose que la concurrence
en économie : un faux nez de l’égalité.
Comment expliquer l’importance de ce livre
en science politique ?
Le Cens caché est une référence de la sociologie
du vote, qui est l’étude de l’influence
des facteurs sociaux (notamment l’éducation
et l’origine socio-économique) sur le choix
de l’électeur. Daniel Gaxie va d’ailleurs
jusqu’à contester l’idée que l’électeur
fait un véritable choix en estimant qu’il
est dépossédé des moyens de connaître
et de maîtriser le champ politique (ses problèmes,
ses acteurs, ses enjeux, etc.). S’il a raison,
alors l’idéal de la démocratie est illusoire,
puisque les élites forment l’opinion de
la population.
À mes yeux, on peut voir la théorie du cens
caché comme la transposition de la sociologie
de Bourdieu sur le thème du vote. Daniel
Gaxie avait fréquenté le séminaire de Bourdieu
dans les années 1970 et il contribuera à
importer ses travaux en science politique.
18ème référence : La Fabrication du consentement
(1988), Edward Herman et Noam Chomsky
Le film Will Hunting raconte l’histoire
d’un Américain surdoué de 20 ans (qui
s’appelle « Will Hunting »). Il est spécial
en ce qu’il refuse le prestige social. Malgré
son don pour les maths et sa vaste culture,
Will vit de petits boulots et passe son temps
avec ses amis d’enfance, qui appartiennent
à la jeunesse désœuvrée de Boston. Au
cours d’une séance avec le psychologue
qui lui sert de mentor, Will inspecte la bibliothèque
du cabinet et se moque du caractère conformiste
des livres qui s’y trouvent. « Et c’est
quoi un putain de bon livre, Will ? », lui
demande alors le psychologue. À quoi Will
répond : « Eh ben c’est le bouquin qui
vous décoiffe ». Et pour prouver qu’il
connaît lui aussi des références subversives,
le psychologue cite La Fabrication du consentement.
Ce livre publié en 1988 est incontournable
parce que c’est la référence moderne sur
la critique des médias. Il est controversé
parce qu’il montre que les élites démocratiques
font un large usage de la propagande (ce qui
invalide le principe même de la démocratie,
puisque les citoyens ne peuvent pas prendre
des décisions éclairées — cette conclusion
rend le livre éminemment subversif). « La
propagande est à la démocratie ce que la
matraque est à la dictature », dit la célèbre
citation de Chomsky.
Pas étonnant, donc, qu’on ne trouve pas
ce livre dans les manuels de science politique.
Il s’agit pourtant bien de science politique,
car c’est une étude empirique des mécanismes
de pouvoir dans les démocraties modernes.
En effet, les équipes des auteurs — Edward
Herman, un économiste prof de finance qui
a apporté son expertise financière, et Noam
Chomsky — leurs équipes ont analysé quantité
d’articles de presse, de rapports de médias,
de documents gouvernementaux et d’autres
formes de données pour mettre à jour le
fonctionnement de la propagande en démocratie.
On associe en général ce livre à Chomsky
parce qu’il est devenu une star intellectuelle
mondiale, mais c’est en réalité Edward
Herman qui est à l’origine du projet.
Concernant la forme, l’intérêt du lecteur
est stimulé par le fait que c’est « un
bouquin qui décoiffe », pour parler comme
Will Hunting — mais il faut quand même
s’accrocher pour aller au bout des 600 pages.
Le style est impersonnel et académique — ce
qui n’est pas étonnant, les auteurs étant
tous les deux profs dans de prestigieuses
universités ; le propos est souvent technique,
et la plongée dans les détails, si elle
donne de la force à la démonstration, n’est
pas passionnante pour l’amateur.
Maintenant, quelles sont les idées essentielles
de La Fabrication du consentement ?
Herman et Chomsky affirment que les médias
ne constituent pas un « quatrième pouvoir
» en démocratie. Dans les faits, ils servent
les autres pouvoirs. Ils font régner une
forme particulière de désinformation dans
l’intérêt des élites politiques et économiques.
Herman et Chomsky soulignent d’abord la
connivence du pouvoir politique et des médias.
Ces derniers favorisent les sources officielles
pour paraître objectifs et pour réduire
les coûts d’enquête. Aux États-Unis,
la Maison-Blanche, le Pentagone et le département
d’État à Washington sont les épicentres
de la production de l’information labellisée.
Les grandes entreprises sont également des
producteurs réguliers d’informations jugées
crédibles. Les sources les plus puissantes
contrôlent également les médias en les
subventionnant directement ou indirectement.
Ainsi, l’État américain (notamment les
départements de l’armée) fait bénéficier
les médias de ses largesses financières,
ce qui lui garantit un accès privilégié
et même un droit de regard sur la production
de l’information.
Une autre manière de fabriquer le consentement
est le contrôle de l’expertise. Indépendants
en apparence, les « experts » médiatiques
sont souvent rémunérés comme consultants,
comme employés de think tanks, ou par le
biais du financement de leurs recherches.
Herman et Chomsky avancent que la création
d’une communauté d’experts est une technique
de propagande mise en œuvre à grande échelle
en toute connaissance de cause. Ainsi, les
industriels américains ont appliqué cette
formule à partir des années 1970 et 1980
en s’attachant les services de milliers
d’intellectuels pour les catapulter dans
les médias.
Mais le mécanisme majeur de la propagande
démocratique est le filtrage de l’information.
Herman et Chomsky théorisent un « modèle
de propagande » comportant cinq filtres.
Le premier filtre est la dimension économique
du média. Les médias les plus puissants
forment ainsi une strate supérieure qui produit
et diffuse une information sélectionnée
vers les strates inférieures et le public.
Le deuxième filtre est le poids de la publicité,
qui marginalise les médias réticents à
orienter leur message dans un sens favorable
aux annonceurs. Le troisième filtre est le
poids des sources jugées les plus crédibles,
qui sélectionnent et formatent l’information
pour les journalistes. Le quatrième filtre
réside dans les contre-feux (divers types
d’organisations, voire d’individus) qui
ont pour fonction de faire pression sur certains
médias sortis du rang, ou sur certaines lignes
éditoriales. Enfin, le cinquième et dernier
filtre est le filtre idéologique principal
de la société (par exemple l’anticommunisme,
ou la guerre contre le terrorisme).
Comme je l’ai dit au début, La Fabrication
du consentement n’est pas une référence
conventionnelle en science politique. Les
auteurs ont beau être des universitaires
réputés, le contenu du livre décoiffe trop.
Mais cela ne l’empêche pas d’avoir une
grande influence sur le débat, aussi bien
dans la culture occidentale qu’en science
politique. En effet, les politistes l’ont
lu, ou tout du moins connaissent ses idées.
La réflexion sur le pouvoir et le rôle des
médias n’est plus la même après l’onde
de choc provoquée par ce livre.
19ème référence : Les trois mondes de l’État-providence
(1990), Gøsta Esping-Andersen
« La société n’existe pas » : cette
fameuse formule de Margaret Thatcher illustre
la remise en cause de l’État-providence
à partir des années 1980. Aux yeux de la
Première ministre du Royaume-Uni — poste
qu’elle a occupé de 1979 à 1990 — à
ses yeux, le citoyen doit prendre en main
sa propre vie ; puis éventuellement prendre
soin de son voisin. Mais ce n’est pas à
l’État de travailler au bien-être de sa
population. Cette ambition, apparaît-il à
la fin du XXe siècle, change profondément
les sociétés occidentales. La réaction
britannique incarnée par Thatcher et la réaction
américaine incarnée par le président Ronald
Reagan illustrent également la diversité
des trajectoires nationales de l’État-providence
(la France, par exemple, élit à la même
époque, en 1981, François Mitterrand, un
président socialiste qui va renforcer l’État-providence).
C’est pour ces raisons que ce livre est
une référence incontournable en science
politique : il montre que l’État-providence
est un moteur essentiel de la transformation
des sociétés occidentales et qu’il prend
des formes différentes — parfois très
différentes — selon les pays. Gøsta Esping-Andersen,
un sociologue danois, fait de la science politique
dans la mesure où il utilise des méthodes
de recherche typiques de la discipline lorsqu’il
compare les systèmes de protection sociale
et des politiques publiques entre différents
pays. Il montre également au tout début
du livre qu’il maîtrise l’histoire des
idées politiques.
Comme beaucoup de livres de ma liste, la forme
de celui-ci n’est pas très attirante. Il
est déjà assez long : plus de 450 pages
pour la traduction française. Si le propos
est accessible pour un lecteur avec une formation
intellectuelle, le style est toutefois très
impersonnel. J’ai également été frappé
par le manque de fluidité : on a l’impression
que les paragraphes sont parachutés les uns
après les autres. Bref, c’est un travail
académique qui n’est vraiment pas fait
pour le grand public, mais pour les pairs
de l’auteur.
Qu’en retenir sur le fond ?
Je pense que deux choses sont essentielles.
Gøsta Esping-Andersen explique tout d’abord
que l’émergence de l’État-providence
correspond à une évolution du capitalisme
vers une forme plus sociale. Cette évolution
se résume dans le concept de « démarchandisation
» : l’intervention de l’État dans l’économie
et la société rend les citoyens moins dépendants
du marché, si bien que le capitalisme ne
peut plus les traiter comme des marchandises.
Ainsi, le marché n’assure qu’une partie
du bien-être de l’individu parce que l’État-providence
le protège des forces du marché. Avec cette
analyse, Gøsta Esping-Andersen adopte la
même perspective que Karl Polanyi dans La
Grande Transformation : l’économie de marché
a profondément transformé la société au
XIXe siècle, et cette transformation a suscité
des réponses politiques pour protéger la
population des troubles engendrés par le
marché.
La seconde chose essentielle dans ce livre
est la célèbre typologie des États-providence.
La comparaison internationale menée par Gøsta
Esping-Andersen lui révèle que les systèmes
nationaux de protection sociale diffèrent
par leurs origines, par leurs motivations,
par leur nature même — mais on peut tout
de même les classifier dans des modèles.
Le sociologue danois fonde sa typologie sur
3 critères : 1° le degré de prise en charge
du bien-être social par l’État-providence
; 2° l’influence la hiérarchie sociale
sur la protection ; et 3° le système familial
dominant.
Selon ces critères, il existe trois régimes
différents d’État-providence (comme le
suggère le titre du livre) :
1. Dans le régime LIBÉRAL, c’est le besoin
qui détermine la protection. L’essentiel
de la couverture sociale est acquis sur le
marché. Du coup, l’État n’intervient
que pour la production de biens sociaux indivisibles,
comme la sécurité, les infrastructures ou
l’éducation. La démarchandisation est
faible, car l’essentiel de la protection
sociale est affecté aux individus les plus
défavorisés qui n’ont pas accès au marché.
De plus, les aides sont ciblées et contribuent
à stigmatiser certaines catégories (les
« pauvres », les « assistés »). Étant
donné la faible protection accordée par
l’État, le rôle de la famille reste important.
Les pays qui correspondent le mieux à ce
modèle sont les États-Unis, le Canada et
l’Australie, la Suisse et le Japon.
2. Dans le régime CORPORATISTE-CONSERVATEUR,
la qualité de la protection sociale dépend
de la profession et des revenus (on parle
de modèle « bismarckien » de protection
sociale parce qu’il est inspiré par les
réformes sociales financées par les cotisations
introduites par le chancelier allemand Otto
von Bismarck à la fin du XIXe siècle). La
démarchandisation est partielle puisque la
protection sociale est liée à la participation
préalable à une activité salariée — en
vertu de quoi ce sont les partenaires sociaux
qui gèrent le système de prestations. Ce
régime est indirectement redistributif, dans
la mesure où les plus pauvres sont plus touchés
par les grands risques sociaux. Il y a un
lien important avec la hiérarchie sociale,
puisque la couverture sociale dépend de l’appartenance
de classe et du degré d’organisation politique
et sociale des salariés. L’adjectif « conservateur
» se justifie par le fait que la protection
sociale est pensée à l’échelle de la
famille et selon le modèle de société promue
par la religion catholique. Les pays les plus
représentatifs de ce modèle sont l’Autriche,
l’Allemagne, la France, l’Italie et la
Belgique.
3. Dans le régime SOCIAL-DÉMOCRATE, la protection
sociale est universelle, car elle repose sur
la citoyenneté. Ainsi, les prestations ne
dépendent pas des revenus et profitent aux
pauvres comme aux riches. Ce modèle de protection
sociale est dit « beveridgien » parce qu’il
est inspiré par le Rapport Beveridge rédigé
en 1942 par l’économiste socialiste britannique
William Beveridge à la demande du gouvernement
britannique, lequel réfléchissait déjà
à la manière de résoudre les problèmes
sociaux tels que la pauvreté, le chômage,
et la maladie — problèmes bien sûr exacerbés
par la guerre mondiale — afin de reconstruire
la société britannique après la guerre).
Ce régime social-démocrate est une fusion
particulière de libéralisme et de socialisme
(dans la mesure où c’est l’État qui
gère le système de prestations). Le rôle
du marché est très faible, ce qui permet
par exemple de percevoir un revenu de remplacement
proche du salaire d’activité lorsqu’on
est au chômage. La hiérarchie sociale influe
peu sur la protection puisque la couverture
et le financement sont universels (ce qui
nécessite un impôt redistributif). Enfin,
ce régime n’est pas conservateur dans la
mesure où il favorise l’autonomie de l’individu
par rapport à la famille (notamment celle
de la femme), ce qui correspond davantage
au modèle de société de la religion protestante.
Les pays les plus représentatifs de ce modèle
sont les pays scandinaves.
Les trois mondes de l’État-providence a
eu une grande influence sur les chercheurs
en science politique — même si cette influence
a été moindre en France. La première raison
de cette influence est que Gøsta Esping-Andersen
a attiré l’attention sur les différences
parfois considérables dans la manière dont
les États contemporains protègent leurs
citoyens des aléas de la vie moderne. Dans
la réalité, il n’existe pas un « État-providence
» ou « État social » comme pouvaient l’écrire
les auteurs antérieurs. La deuxième raison
de l’influence de ce livre est que chaque
pays élabore un modèle d’État-providence
en fonction de son histoire, de sa culture,
et de ses mentalités. Enfin, ce livre a eu
une grande influence en science politique
parce qu’il a été séminal à l’égard
de la recherche comparée sur les États-providence
(c’est-à-dire qu’il a été fondateur
pour ce champ de recherche). C’est certes
un champ de recherche précis — mais étant
donné le poids de l’État-providence dans
les sociétés occidentales, c’est un sujet
essentiel pour comprendre le monde.
20ème référence : Principes du gouvernement
représentatif (1995), Bernard Manin
« Ce n’est pas élire des gens de temps
en temps qui fait une démocratie, c’est
de voter des projets », estime l’écrivain
Michel Houellebecq. Au début des années
2010, il répétait dans les interviews qu’il
ne voterait plus en France tant qu’elle
ne serait pas devenue une vraie démocratie,
c’est-à-dire une démocratie directe. Ses
formules chocs reprises par les médias — par
exemple « La France n’est pas une démocratie
» — de telles formules choquaient l’opinion
publique française. Et pourtant, il existe
de sérieux arguments pour défendre l’idée
qu’une démocratie représentative n’est
pas une véritable démocratie.
On trouve ces arguments dans Principes du
gouvernement représentatif de Bernard Manin.
Ce livre est la référence incontournable
en science politique sur le thème de la démocratie
représentative, et plus généralement sur
l’évolution de l’idée de démocratie
dans le contexte moderne (disons après la
Révolution française). Comme d’autres
références de ma liste, celle-ci se situe
à l'intersection de la science politique
et de la philosophie politique. Mais c’est
bien de la science politique parce que Bernard
Manin examine comment la démocratie a évolué
dans la pratique au cours de l’histoire
; parce qu’il s’interroge sur le fonctionnement
réel et les mécanismes spécifiques de ce
régime dans les sociétés modernes ; et
enfin, parce qu’il ne se contente pas d’une
analyse abstraite de concepts fondamentaux
comme celui de la représentation — il aborde
également leur traduction concrète.
Ce livre d’un peu plus de 350 pages n’est
pas une lecture facile. Certes, le style de
Bernard Manin est clair et ne verse presque
jamais dans le jargon. Mais le ton est impersonnel
; le propos est dense ; souvent théorique,
précis et technique ; et les paragraphes
sont longs. À mes yeux, ça n’a pas de
sens de lire ce livre si on ne le lit pas
lentement, en prenant des notes, et avec l’objectif
de devenir un expert sur le thème de la démocratie.
Si Bernard Manin n’est pas facile à lire,
il est en revanche très éclairant. Il montre
que les sociétés contemporaines amalgament
la démocratie et le régime représentatif.
Les débats constitutionnels dans lesquels
intervenaient les inventeurs du régime représentatif
(notamment lors des Révolutions américaine
et française à la fin du XVIIIe siècle)
— ces débats révèlent que ​​les inventeurs
du régime représentatif n’avaient en réalité
pas cherché à élaborer une forme de démocratie.
En effet, le régime représentatif n’équivaut
pas à une forme de gouvernement du peuple.
Même parler de démocratie « indirecte » est
une erreur. Le modèle historique de la démocratie
athénienne permet de comprendre ce qui rend
un régime politique réellement démocratique.
Dans ce modèle, le peuple ne détient pas
tous les pouvoirs, mais le tirage au sort
assure l’égale probabilité d’accéder
à des fonctions de pouvoir. Ce mode de sélection
des gouvernants présuppose que l’alternance
du commandement et de l’obéissance (ou
la « rotation des charges »), ainsi que
le renouvellement fréquent des gouvernants
— ces principes sont nécessaires pour que
le peuple reste maître de son destin. En
comparaison, l’élection apparaît comme
un mode de sélection aristocratique. Pour
autant, les inventeurs des régimes représentatifs
modernes ont choisi la sélection par l’élection
sans même débattre du tirage au sort. Comment
l’expliquer ? C’est parce que l’élection,
contrairement au tirage au sort, produit le
consentement des gouvernés à l’autorité
(on accepte d’obéir au maître qu’on
choisit, on est plus réticent si c’est
le hasard qui le choisit).
En fait, le gouvernement représentatif est
un régime mixte : il combine des propriétés
aristocratiques et démocratiques. Cet équilibre
se retrouve dans les quatre grands principes
du gouvernement représentatif : la sélection
des gouvernants par l’élection à intervalles
réguliers ; la relative liberté d’action
des gouvernants ; la libre expression de l’opinion
des gouvernés ; et la mise en débat des
décisions publiques. Parmi ces principes,
l’élection est celui qui donne au gouvernement
représentatif sa dimension aristocratique.
Cette dimension réside dans la conviction
que les élus ne sont pas des citoyens ordinaires,
mais que leur statut social est plus élevé
que celui des électeurs. La dimension démocratique
du régime représentatif réside, elle, à
la fois dans l’élection — qui confère
une voix égale à tout citoyen et soumet
les élites au choix du peuple — et dans
la représentation, en vertu de laquelle les
gouvernants doivent tenir compte de l’opinion
publique.
Dans les faits, Bernard Manin distingue 3
formes de gouvernement représentatif : le
parlementarisme, la démocratie de partis,
et la démocratie du public. Le parlementarisme
est la première forme historique du gouvernement
représentatif. Il se caractérise par l’élection
d’une élite de notables. Puis le gouvernement
représentatif évolue avec l’avènement
des partis de masse au tournant du XIXe siècle.
L’élite sociale des notables est remplacée
par une élite de professionnels de la politique,
les militants et les hommes d’appareil.
Enfin, le gouvernement représentatif mute
encore à la fin des années 1980 : on passe
à la « démocratie du public ». Les nouvelles
techniques de communication et l’évolution
du pouvoir changent le vote : les électeurs
sélectionnent davantage une personne sur
son image, plutôt qu’un programme ou un
camp politique. L’élite des militants et
les hommes d’appareil est donc remplacée
par une élite de figures médiatiques moins
proches des électeurs. Cette nouvelle forme
a l’inconvénient d’accroître la distance
sociale entre les représentants et les représentés,
ce qui nourrit le sentiment d’une crise
démocratique.
Comme ce livre a été publié il y a moins
de 30 ans, il est encore un peu tôt pour
évaluer son influence, mais 2 éléments
me paraissent importants :
1. Ce livre donne une vision plus réaliste
de la démocratie. La profondeur historique
et comparative de l’analyse de Bernard Manin
rétablit des nuances cruciales, et freine
par là la tendance des sociétés occidentales
à idéaliser la démocratie.
2. Ce livre préfigure les réflexions sur
l’effet politique des nouvelles technologies
de communication. Le concept de « démocratie
du public » apparaît particulièrement pertinent
à l’ère d’internet et des réseaux sociaux.
Les médias et l’opinion publique ont désormais
un rôle prépondérant dans la vie démocratique.
Si vous aimez l’esprit de cette vidéo — à
savoir découvrir des choses intéressantes
en allant à l’essentiel et sans se prendre
la tête — alors vous aimerez probablement
mon programme Culture Express.
C’est un programme méthodique pour devenir
facilement une personne cultivée en seulement
quelques mois.
Il couvre tous les domaines de la culture
générale : vous maîtriserez les connaissances
essentielles sur l’histoire de l’humanité,
sur l’histoire de France, en économie,
en science politique, en psychologie, en science,
en littérature, en art, en religion, et en
philosophie.
Vous ne serez plus jamais à court de choses
à dire et vous gagnerez la confiance nécessaire
pour briller en toutes circonstances.
Vous pouvez en savoir plus en cliquant sur
le lien qui s’affiche en haut à droite,
ou bien sur celui qui est dans la description,
ou bien encore en tapant directement l’adresse
qui s’affiche à l’écran dans la barre
de recherche.
Mais je pense que la meilleure façon de vous
donner une idée du programme est d’écouter
ce que les membres ont à en dire.
Valentine, qui reconnaît l’énorme quantité
de travail que ce programme a représenté
pour moi, dit que « c’est une véritable
mine d’or [...] L’essentiel est là, tout
est simple, pratique, très bien expliqué,
concentré, il n’y a plus qu’à recopier
et à apprendre. Ce travail est vraiment formidable
et passionnant. »
Maxence m’écrit directement dans les commentaires
en-dessous d’une vidéo du programme : « Ta
formation est vraiment remarquable. J'étais
un peu dubitatif étant donné le prix initial
mais je ne regrette pas, c'est un vrai travail
de synthèse que tu nous proposes et le format
vidéo est très adapté pour moi qui ai une
mémoire essentiellement auditive. Le choix
des thèmes et des chapitres est pertinent
et je trouve que tu as trouvé la dose d'approfondissement
parfaite ; à la fois précis mais sans fioritures
! »
Vincent, lui, fait carrément ma pub : « J’ai
d’ailleurs recommandé votre formation à
ma sœur qui travaille comme diplomate [...]. La
semaine dernière, elle a déjà eu l’occasion
de mettre à profit, dans ses discussions,
les connaissances que vous avez diffusées.
»
Vous verrez d’autres témoignages comme
ceux-ci dans les commentaires si vous rejoignez
le programme. Et si vous vous inscrivez, vous
bénéficiez d'une garantie résultats : une
fois que vous aurez terminé le programme,
je vous rembourserai intégralement si vous
estimez que vous n’avez pas acquis une solide
culture générale.
Si vous voulez en savoir plus, cliquez sur
le lien qui s’affiche en haut à droite,
ou bien sur celui qui est dans la description,
ou bien encore tapez directement l’adresse
qui s’affiche à l’écran dans la barre
de recherche.
Plus de 800 membres ont déjà tiré parti
de ce programme, et je serais ravi qu’il
en soit de même pour vous.
Dans tous les cas, j’espère que cette vidéo
vous a plu.
Je suis Romain, et vous, vous étiez sur 1000
idées de culture générale.
Rappelez-vous que vous n’avez pas besoin
de vous prendre la tête pour vous intéresser
au meilleur de la pensée.